this video is about two things the first
is
scp-096 also known as the shy guy a
horrific monster who murders anyone and
anything unfortunate enough to look at
its face directly or through photos or
videos the second is you because we
asked you for your favorite questions
theories and hypothetical situations
involving 096. we even asked if you
thought someone would be safe from 096
on the moon and you delivered if you
haven't watched our first video on the
infamous shy guy we recommend checking
that out first but feel free to stick
around even if you haven't first of all
let's take a look at the questions you
had about the scp foundation's most
dangerous introvert and see if we can't
find some answers how close would you
have to be to trigger it like if it was
five kilometers away would it still
count the short answer is that 096's
homicidal rage can be triggered from
pretty much any distance we'll get into
some of the potentially crazy extents of
this later on but if you see the shy
guy's face while you're sharing a
dimension with him you're in serious
trouble people who viewed the creature's
face in different countries or even
miles underwater have met gruesome ends
five kilometers would definitely not
keep you safe what were his origins and
how strong is he compared to scp-682
the origins of
scp-096 are still shrouded in mystery
all we know for sure is that he was
discovered by the foundation in a snowy
mountainous region as for physical
durability he's about even with 682 as
both survived their encounter we know
682 has the psychological advantage
though as 096 has been terrified of the
lizard ever since they met in cross
testing however you could argue that 096
is technically more dangerous since on
mike 682 096 has never been pacified
before killing its intended target while
on a rampage if he goes into an
unstoppable attack mode when someone
sees his face shouldn't you not show his
face in the thumbnail thankfully
according to the official documents
artistic representations like paintings
or digitally drawn youtube thumbnails
have no effect only actual photographs
or videos of the creature can be deadly
so you're safe unless we decide to do a
096 face reveal to celebrate our next
100 000 subscribers of course this leads
us to our next question if it attacks
you when you look at it then how did the
scientist draw the picture of the thing
without looking at it that's a good
question and also one that occurred to
the foundation scientists who came up
with an extremely elaborate solution
they put a d-class tattoo artist inside
a diving bell miles underwater and had
him unseal a photograph of the creature
before drawing a copy this copy was then
released from the diving bell in a
sealed container before 096 inevitably
got to the poor d-class does the shy guy
have to be viewed through a good quality
image to enter a rage state
unfortunately
no
even the most poorly rendered or
minuscule image of 096's face is a death
sentence one of the most infamous
incidents resulted from a man seeing a
small dot that was only a few pixels
wide in a photo from an old ski trip the
dot was 096 taken from a mile away no
true image of 096 is safe regardless of
size in some canons despite 096 being
referred to as indestructible the
foundation managed to terminate it after
many attempts and even more bureaucracy
how did they do it well a lot of 096's
body has been blown away by conventional
arms fire its hyper tough skeleton is
what has given it such an indestructible
reputation in one tale though foundation
researchers actually used this to their
advantage and employed the use of the
neck snapping killer sculpture scp-173
after using 173 to damage 096's bones
powerful acid was injected into the
skeleton destroying it from within
though of course this isn't the official
ending of the 096 story because the scp
foundation doesn't have a single
unifying cannon that's enough questions
now it's time for you to school us let's
look at some of your favorite theories
about the shy guy starting with i
sometimes like to imagine that 096 is
nice but he can't control when someone
sees him and after he kills the person
he starts to cry because he didn't want
to kill them there is actually some
evidence to suggest that scp-096
might not want to kill a great example
of this is its cross test with scp-978
a camera which reveals the deepest
desires of whoever or whatever is in its
photos the photo it took of 096 showed
that it had completely disappeared from
the photo showing its deepest desire was
to just be invisible and unseen maybe it
wants to disappear because it doesn't
want to hurt anybody regarding the moon
question i think scp-096 would probably
stay in that hostile state until you
came back at which point it would
promptly rip you to shreds and do
whatever it does to your mutilated
corpse based on what we know about prior
096 incidents this feels incredibly
likely it's also possible that it might
enter its docile state before becoming
aggressive again when you return to its
murder range you really don't want to
find out either way he can just jump to
the moon easy he does squats and
containment all the time while it's
scrawny physique doesn't make it seem
like 096 understands the concept of
exercise there aren't any cameras in
096's cell so technically we can't prove
it isn't doing squats to pass the time
in there i really doubt a blind person
would be safe from his effect since 096
has the iq of a newborn baby i think he
will count it as looking at him this is
an interesting theory however seeing as
096 is able to sense when people see its
face from entire continents away the way
it knows if you can see its face might
be a little more psychic in nature
therefore it's probable that it wouldn't
mistakenly kill someone who hasn't
actually seen its face such as a person
who is blind to deal with him in my
opinion simply frees him either in space
or in the mountains his body shuts down
and when looked at it it will not react
correctly it is simply asleep while we
don't know how
scp-096 would react to a zero-g
environment for a creature that's always
nude it seems extremely tolerant to the
cold when it was first found it was
lurking in icy mountains and a
foundation agent commented on the fact
it wasn't even shivering despite the
incredibly low temperatures but who
knows if there's a temperature out there
that's too low even for the shy guy if
someone looks at it in china and it's in
the u.s then you get on its back you'll
get a free piggyback ride to china it's
a free trip to china and all it costs is
a human life that's my theory
technically it'd be at the cost of two
human lives unless you wore a diving
suit with plenty of oxygen 096 has
proven to be an extremely proficient
swimmer but you'd have to maintain your
grip across the entire pacific ocean
while it journeys to china in other
words it's technically possible but we
here at scp explained would rather pay
for the round-trip flight to each their
own though but that's enough theories
for now let's move on to the main event
hypotheticals you pose some great
possible scenarios involving scp-096
so we're going to see if we can find the
answers what would happen if someone
looked at a picture of it while in or
before entering another scp's pocket
dimension or mirror dimension there
aren't any canon examples to prove
either way but if there's any kind of
consistent entry point into this
dimension it's likely that 096 would
find a way to follow you in if not it's
very possible that it may just wait for
you to eventually return before bringing
the metaphorical hammer down on you so
technically if you were pulled into the
old man's pocket dimension and he closed
the portal you'd be safe from 096 but
then you've got a whole other problem to
deal with what happens if a person sees
his face then gets their memory of the
creature wiped considering how good the
foundation seems to be at wiping
people's memories and their access to
amnestics if this worked they probably
would have made it standard procedure by
now so it's unlikely what happens if a
person looked at it and that person then
went on a plane or just staying in the
air or space what would it do 096 has
shown the ability to jump up and destroy
low-flying aircraft but otherwise it's
likely that the creature would probably
run to a point directly below you and
remain there until you touch back down
since you'll need food and water at some
point and aircrafts need fuel you'd
probably just be prolonging the
inevitable what if the young girl was
around it so it tried to attack her but
died trying this is another interesting
possibility
scp-053 is a girl capable of causing
homicidal urges but causes fatal heart
attacks in those who attack her while we
can't know for sure how a meeting
between 096 and 053 would go we can use
her encounter with 682 as a potential
template aggressive scps like the hard
to kill reptile perhaps having an innate
knowledge of the danger that comes from
attacking 0-5-3 tend to become strangely
docile around her it's possible that
0-9-6 would do the same would we be able
to control scp-096 with the help of
scp-035
the possessive mask aka scp-035
is undeniably a lot more intelligent
than 096 and has even been shown to
respond to reason on occasion it's also
been able to control almost every other
entity it's been placed on the problem
is if the mask was placed on 096 and it
was somehow effective the result may be
even more dangerous than 096 an
intelligent monster with an
indestructible and highly dangerous body
there's no telling whether 0-3-5 would
slowly break down 0-9-6 into sludge the
way it does to humans in which case we
would be left with an immortal
096035 combo so maybe it's best that we
never find out if someone were to be in
the infinite ikea and looked at a
picture of its face could it finally be
contained and if someone else looked at
a picture of it outside of the infinite
ikea could it escape and kill them if so
how long would it take it this is a
great question and while the infinite
ikea is a terrifying maze
scp-096 has an advantage here that we
don't not only can it rip through
anything in the way with its super
strength it has an innate sense of where
its victim is therefore regardless of
whether you're inside or out
scp-096 will still come straight to you
to exact your horrible fate but at least
you can enjoy the meatballs while you
wait right and finally what would happen
if 096 were led into a room full of
mirrors and allowed or made to look at
its own face would it smash the mirrors
or try to rip itself to pieces this is
still a hotly debated issue to this day
which thanks to the no cannon nature of
the scp foundation does not have a
definitive answer some theorize that
this would at least be an effective
deterrent against scp-096
while others suggest that it wouldn't be
effective because many believe that 096
is actually blind and thus cannot see
its own face it can only sense when
other people see it again we don't quite
know for sure but it's likely to remain
one of the most contentious issues
around the shy guy for a long time to
come and there you have it folks our
very first questions and theories video
we loved hearing what you had to say so
keep an eye on our community post for
the next one are there other scps you'd
like to see us cover and explained or
theory videos let us know in the
comments and subscribe to scp explained
and turn on notifications for new scp
videos every single week you've been
walking for days your body aches you're
dripping with sweat from the heat of the
sun bearing down overhead and yet you're
wrapped up in layers upon layers of
clothing even your face is covered and
you're wearing thick black goggles so
that not a single centimeter of your
body is exposed your journey has been
long and you feel like you might die
from exhaustion or from overheating due
to these multiple layers of clothes but
dying is better than being exposed you
saw it happen when your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those you used to know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distressed signal
coming from a nearby scp foundation
containment facility site 46 any kind of
survivors would be better than nothing
no matter what kind of sorry shape they
were in as long as they were still human
you find your way to an opening in the
side of a mountain and slide into the
cave hoping you weren't spotted the
whole world is crawling with those
things now you can't let yourself be
seen as you trudge down the cave towards
the entrance you see what looks like a
huge black snail trail splattered on the
ground leading into the facility you try
to avoid it and press on you don't even
need a key card to enter the door has
been left ajar the facility reeks of
those things but you can't see any of
them you just hope they've moved on and
left some human survivors in their wake
the place looks abandoned every step you
take echoes through the empty halls when
you find that the elevator's out you
take the stairs all the way down to
level b5 ketter containment lucky for
you it seems all the cells are empty now
the horrors that were kept inside of
them have all long since flown the coup
you keep following that slimy black
trail until you find an abandoned office
there are no people here anymore just a
broken barricade some empty medicine
bottles and a bucket that the people
inside the office had apparently been
using as a toilet you breathe a sigh of
disappointment at finding no one alive
here but you're at least relieved to be
out of the sun you can finally remove
your jacket and head wrap with your
uncovered eyes you notice that a nearby
computer terminal is still powered up
you sit down at the desk and turn on the
monitor because of the emergency
procedures put into place in a k-class
scenario like this safeguards no longer
apply you can access all the information
you need up to and including finding out
what actually happened in the dull glow
of a nearby emergency light you see a
dark shape slumping through the halls in
shadow you tense up then exhale as it
slithers off into an adjoining hall
you're safe for now the terminal has
finally loaded and authenticated your
access you're staring at the file for sd
lock's proposal for scp-001
when day breaks it's the only name you
can give the apocalypse your world is
currently experiencing this is one of
the only anomalies in the entire history
of the scp foundation to be given the
apollyon containment class meaning
containment is truly impossible
scp-001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the scp foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
scp-001
and those effects are beyond horrifying
the scp foundation administrator
released an urgent memo telling
foundation personnel to make their way
to site 19 at all costs because they
need all the help they can get those
exposed to scp-001 in the process are no
longer considered human their new
designation is scp-001
these new entities are to be avoided at
all costs but in case of emergencies the
administrator says it is permitted to
cut off parts of your transformed
comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation no attempt should be made to
kill them since you won't succeed you'll
just put yourself at risk when the sun
changed and became
scp-001 it instantly affected 6.8
billion innocent people the second the
visible light touched them whether it
was from the sun itself or even
reflected off the moon their bodies
liquefied melting like candle wax into
puddles of living gelatinous slime this
effect isn't isolated to humans either
any biological entity exposed to
sunlight immediately underwent the same
irreversible melting process into
scp-001-a
and the horror had only just begun
people transformed into
scp-001a will remain shades of their
former intelligence and personality they
may even try to will their new gooey
mass into a shape resembling their
original form however these individuals
will lose their sense of self if they
come into contact with other instances
of
scp-001-a when they come together
001-a instances will bond on a molecular
level waiting up into horrific giant
blobs with only one purpose
integrating more matter into their
bodies
that's why they have to be avoided at
all costs you continue to search the
computer terminal for answers perhaps
there was some kind of contingency plan
put in place for this some way to
reverse the effects or at least escape
the nightmare earth has become instead
you find a series of attachments linked
to the scp-001
file detailing what seems to be the last
days of the people who barricaded
themselves in the facility most
prominent among these were researcher dr
logan igata her partner ari a security
officer named commander anad and a few
others dr igata had locked herself in
the office where she recorded her final
messages to the world in the first audio
log dr igata and her companions seemed
afraid but hopeful that there may be
some way out of this situation dr egada
reported that most of the workers at the
facility were transformed during the
initial event their melted bodies had
fused outside the facility and now they
were trying to bust their way back in
the defenses had held so far though and
they seemed confident they would hold
long enough for them to figure out a way
to escape this awful situation you open
the second attachment an incident report
and realized things may not have been as
hopeful as dr regatta led on she
reported hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever-growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining d-classes wearing
a full protective suit he didn't last
long the huge creature grabbed him with
tentacles made of reconstituted flesh it
began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for mercy it was a monster
made of dozens of people and animals he
could never overpower it the second the
sun touched his skin he melted away and
was absorbed by the great mass holding
him in place
guns were ineffective against these
scp-001-a super entities fire would do
no good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then
not permanently there was one ray of
light in the darkness the site director
had a secret tunnel underneath his
office connected to a tram that could
hopefully take them directly to site 19
without risk of scp-001 exposure it was
a good plan and by far the best option
they had available to them but the best
plans often don't work in practice you
open the next detachment on the terminal
this time it's a video feed you can
actually see dr logan igata and she
looks harrowed by what she's experienced
as it turns out while the others
including her partner ari attempted to
escape through the tunnel something had
happened dr igata heard ari's voice over
her radio but there was something wrong
with it it was too low too guttural and
filled with gurgles
scp-001 had gotten her she was changed
the monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
escape now seemed gone ari told dr igata
that it would be fine that it was such a
bright beautiful sunny day outside and
she was wasting it locked up inside that
office she tormented dr egada with their
shared memories of picnics in the park
on sunny days in the past the monster
with ari's voice did everything it could
to try to convince dr igata to give up
and join them but she wasn't ready to go
just yet you look away from the screen
when you hear a sound in the corner you
see a dark puddle of some unknown
substance and then some skeletal hands
rising out of it the hands are pulling
themselves out of the puddle followed by
a skeletal face covered in matted hair
you have to stop yourself from screaming
until a flash from a nearby security
light makes the figure disappear it's a
normal puddle once again your mind is
playing tricks on you you open the next
attachment another video and see that dr
igota's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of blood-stained parchment
covered in strange symbols it got a
ranted about her theory what if zero
zero one took the minds and bodies of
its victims but not their souls through
performing some kind of arcane blood
ritual she hoped to at least rescue and
keep the soul of ahri even if her mind
and body were lost you open the next
attachment it seemed that agata's ritual
worked but not in the way she hoped the
twisted soul of ari driven mad by
scp-001 had taken over the file it
begins corrupting the text of the
scp-001 file into crazy ranting about
how futile it is to fight it then cuts
to an even more frightening video feed
dr egada in her sleep tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner
of her office the camera approaches her
in first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through dr igota's hair it's
that exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier you
must have seen ari's lingering spirit
with a lump in your throat you open the
next attachment and watch the video you
see dr regatta now truly broken she'd
been haunted by ari's demonic spirit for
a long time now and it has clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes there
is only one way to escape but not like
this she doesn't want the gun to draw
attention to her body she doesn't want
to become part of that mass even if she
is dead she opens a drawer on her desk
she's recording at and places the gun
inside dr igata then apologizes to her
loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun dr egada was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment the text
has been changed entirely the file on
scp-001 is now a poem an ode to the sun
and to ultimate togetherness then a
video file spontaneously opens itself on
the screen it's a video of you
shot from behind you see those oily
skeletal hands reaching for you in the
dark just like they did with dr egada in
that moment you panic and fire the gun
behind you hoping to scare off the
spirit instead the sound of the gunshots
attracts something far worse the immense
blob of screaming melted flesh charges
towards the office you try to barricade
the door but it is not enough the flesh
seeps and bursts through and grabs you
in its meaty tentacles you scream and
try to escape but it won't save you
nothing will save you the flesh carries
you upstairs out through the empty halls
out into the cave you can see the light
in the distance as the blob ferries you
towards it you won't be alone for much
longer in fact you won't be alone ever
again
working at the scp foundation might just
be the most exciting job a person can
ask for and by exciting we mean that if
you work as an scp field operative
researcher or mobile task force member
you're much more likely to die a
horrific death on the job than say a
plumber but at least you get the honor
of proudly saying that you're the first
line of defense between the normal world
and the terrifying domain of the
anomalous well unless you're one of the
it guys then your work life is likely as
tedious and uneventful as the computer
tech guy working on the geek squad but
nothing is ever normal when it comes to
the scp foundation where even the person
whose job is helping other staff members
reset their email passwords may run into
the supernatural welcome to the strange
and frightening world of pattern
screamers and specifically
scp-000
scp-000 was first discovered completely
on accident by technical researcher
david rosen a man intrinsically
connected to the pattern screamers
lurking on the scp foundation computer
database technical researcher rosen is
actually somewhat of a celebrity around
the foundation's staff due to the fact
that he's so perfectly mediocre at what
he does his job as the glorified i.t guy
at the scp foundation was previously
held by the more qualified researcher
patrick gephardt but rosen was called in
to replace him after gephart
mysteriously disappeared while on the
job since 2012 rosen has been site 19's
user level tech support wizard but the
best thing that can really be said about
his job competency is that he's got a
100 attendance record he seems to live
out of his office which is described as
the filthiest at the whole foundation
every inch of the floor is covered in
old broken computer parts and the air is
stale with dust and the twin odors of
sweat and lithium grease it's a place so
inhospitable that the foundation has
seriously considered bottling the stench
as a kind of chemical deterrent while
technical director rosen isn't good at
his job per se he isn't technically bad
enough at it to justify the time and
resources it would take to replace him
but the worst part about rosen isn't his
performance it's his truly rotten
attitude he's universally described by
his colleagues as being rude grumpy and
combative with patience that's far too
short for someone working in tech
support and while rosen does have a real
fear that the ghost of researcher
gephardt is stalking him he was about to
have his first actual brush with the
supernatural it all started when he
began receiving automated repair tickets
for scp-000
a file that had no reason to exist as
any long-time follower of the scp
foundation will know the universal
designation for the first cluster of
scps to be discovered is
scp-001 there is no scp-000
it simply doesn't exist and when rosen
first found the file lurking on the
database he found that it was filled
with worthless nonsense the object class
was recorded as null the special
containment procedures read error field
containment underscore procedures does
not exist and the mess of a description
simply read internal system error field
undefined please contact system
administrator over and over again
becoming more mangled and nonsensical
each time technical director rosen who
could never resist an opportunity to
complain decided to leave an angry
administrator's note on the useless file
he claimed that this pile of junk data
was sending out pointless repair tickets
because of its broken syntax clogging up
the system and preventing him from doing
actual work on meaningful files he
assumed that this was all down to the
database not knowing how to react to
having files logged with insufficient
information and he suppressed all future
repair tickets from
scp-000 before declaring the matter over
and done with what the pig-headed
technical director didn't realize was
that he was suppressing a call for help
from an entity trapped in the white
space below the article itself it was a
being born into a pure white world of
absolute nothingness an entity with no
name and no place but it was somehow
capable of thought its panicked inner
monologue is readable in the hidden text
which takes the form of a rambling
stream of consciousness the being first
described coming to life in this empty
world with no memories of where it was
or even how it got there it spent what
could have been years exploring the
empty wasteland occasionally it would
see horrific monsters pop up around it
but only for a split second the entity
continued to wander and little by little
the existential dread mounted as they
realized that it may truly be stuck here
in oblivion forever the entity only had
one word to go on a word repeated by
some of the monsters it encountered
foundation the entity had no idea what
this foundation even was but it grew to
hate and fear it was this foundation the
one that trapped it here the entity had
all the time in the world to speculate
on it eventually the entity found its
voice like any sentient creature in
trouble it began to call for help
eventually screaming just hoping someone
would notice it these pleas likely
translated into the frequent it repair
tickets a coded sos an attempt to show
that everything was not as it appeared
on the scp-000
file perhaps the entity may have found
help if researcher gephardt was still
working at the foundation but instead
its cries fell on the ignorant ears of
technical director rosen it may as well
have been speaking to a brick wall rosen
who had all the investigative zeal of
paul blart mall cop made sure that these
cries would never lead to the entity's
freedom when he suppressed the repair
tickets he had trapped the entity in a
private blank hell forever hating a life
it didn't choose and could never escape
a relentless existential nightmare this
is the gist of your average patterned
screamer pattern screamers are a perfect
example of literally making something
out of nothing they are often a kind of
floating consciousness created from
nothing trapped in pockets of
nothingness between the fabric of
reality driven mad by the purgatory-like
nature of their existence they're less
living entities and more conceptual
constructs pure ideas that just happen
to be self-aware of their own existence
in their private hellish voids the
scp-00 file a file for an anomaly that
doesn't exist and thus had no reason to
exist is a perfect breeding ground for a
patterned screamer but sadly for the
pattern screamer in question technical
director rosen had no idea this isn't
the only time that rosen had run into a
pattern screamer without even knowing
either and just like the first case he
was with no help whatsoever this one
began with scp-s an otherwise empty file
containing only this image director
winters a foundation administrator
wondered why this file even existed
enter technical director rosen filled
with equal parts sarcasm and
insubordination he gave a condescending
reply to director winters saying that
the file was there to test the filing
system and the image was likely just a
placeholder winters never should have
been on the page anyway according to
rosen director winters was annoyed at
rosen's typically rude tone and asked
him to make the purpose of the article
clearer in the article itself in
response rosen did as he was told
filling the article in the most
sarcastic manner possible the whole
thing was essentially a middle finger to
director winters for having the audacity
to even ask rosen signed off with there
finished i certainly hope i have been
clear enough to anyone who may have
accidentally accessed this page through
what i am sure is no fault of their own
so we won't have any more incredibly
competent directors bugging the tech
team about this page and once again
technical researcher rosen was too busy
being a rude unpleasant jerk to notice
he was practically staring another
pattern screamer in the face this
pattern screamer or rather hive of
pattern screamers were trapped even
deeper than the one in scp-000
this one was hidden in the very source
code of scps where a chorus of enraged
voices screamed the following pretend
monster just for a minute pretend you
were the size of an amoeba dwarfed by
even the smallest of bugs pretend you
didn't hold the world in a glass cage
pretend you were the one being held by
something greater than yourself would
you still be laughing at your triumphs
would you still feel pride in what you
were even as pitifully small as you
would be
of course you would because you are
arrogant and stupid if you haven't
guessed yet we hate you
this pattern screamer is clearly more
aware of its pitiful station in
existence than the zero zero zero
pattern screamer and as a result it's
not so much depressed as it is furious
though at this point you've probably
figured out that even the entities who
have the most casual brushes with
technical researcher rosen end up
getting infuriated but while you may
have gotten the impression that all
pattern screamers are sad little
entities worthy of our sympathy and pity
there's at least one pattern screamer
that's actually incredibly dangerous
this is scp-393
the ultimate pattern screamer in terms
of both size and effect it's an anomaly
so strange it defies typical containment
classification and it bears a level 5
security lock meaning only those on the
level of the legendary o5 council are
clear to even know about it its greatest
containment procedure is the
preservation of the very idea that
scp-3930 does not exist because the
alternative has terrifying implications
for all involved
scp-3930 is a one kilometer area in
russia that is filled with non-existence
to even call it a white void would be
inaccurate because it implies the
existence of the color white and the
existence of the concept of a void
nothing exists with an
scp-3930 and anyone who directly
observes 3930 runs the risk of actively
increasing its power that's why special
containment procedures dictate that
anyone who observes 3930 must be forced
to walk into it afterwards which results
in them ceasing to exist they're
destroyed on the deepest level that
anything can be destroyed the very idea
of them ceases to be another reason that
scp-3930 is so special is that because
it's the largest area of nothing in
existence interacting directly with our
reality it's the only place that a huge
number of patterned screamers can be
directly observed by humans they're
described as being like sentient
hallucinations one researcher suggests
that these pattern screamers are created
by the way the psyche shatters when
brought into contact with raw true
nothingness the nothingness acts like a
hateful mirror to our worst thoughts
reflecting them back at us in the forms
of restless screamers regardless of what
they actually are one thing is for sure
coming into direct contact with one of
these screamers is a harrowing
experience in the end it just goes to
show that pattern screamers are a
complex entity they can range from
microscopic to massive from pitiful to
downright terrifying and the sad result
is that in either case nothing can
really be done to stop them it's just as
impossible to stop the nothingness
existing in
scp-3930 as it is to save the entity
trapped in the white spaces of scp-000
maybe the best option is to actually be
more like technical director rosen keep
your head down focus instead on your own
petty worries and bask in the warm bliss
that can only come with having no idea
what you're dealing with the one
downside is that this may make you a
pretty lousy i.t guy
here we go again
it's time to return to the acid-filled
containment chamber of
scp-682 more commonly known as the hard
to destroy reptile we've spoken about
him and the ways the scp foundation has
attempted to destroy him in a previous
video but as we said back then we really
only scratch the surface of the huge
number of insane ways the foundation has
tried to wipe this cranky lizard off the
face of the earth today we're filling in
some of the cracks and taking a look at
the secret test logs detailing the
foundation's unsuccessful quest to
finally destroy
scp-682 some of these may surprise you
and if you're a real scp expert you may
just recognize some familiar faces we
meet along the way
esteemed foundation researcher dr alto
clef famed for his somewhat
unconventional personality entered the
test chamber to see if he could
intimidate the beast to death this
resulted in a long-staring contest
between dr clef ann 682 towards the end
of the competition dr cleff began to
lose his nerve he tried to leave the
room only to find that the door was
locked causing him to swear loudly dr
cleff who always tries to find the most
direct solution to his problems blew up
the door with plastic explosives and ran
off the result test failed next came
scp-662 a silver handbell that summons
the supernaturally helpful butler mr
deeds when mr deeds was summoned
foundation researchers asked him if he
could kill scp-682
deeds politely explained that he
wouldn't be capable of killing 682 it's
just too strong when he asked if he
could at least incapacitate 682 he
replied that the best way to do this
would be to poison himself and allow 682
to eat his body but this he reminded
would only be a temporary problem for
the lizard another test failed the
foundation brought in
scp-689 a terrifying soapstone statue of
a sitting skeleton that can kill you if
you see it and then stop paying
attention to it 682 first observed the
statue and then the foundation turned
off the lights when they turned them
back on
scp-682 appeared to be dead in a puddle
of gray and black liquid d-class
personnel were sent in to confirm that
682 was actually dead but it instead got
up and killed them researchers theorized
that 682's definition of life is not
quite the same as ours rendering 689's
death-related powers ineffective test
failed yet again
scp-807 was next up to bat this is an
anomalous salmon-colored ceramic dinner
plate with the words last chance diner
printed on the edges in white any food
placed on it becomes irresistible by any
definition but when the food is consumed
it causes immediate cardiac arrest due
to the sudden clogging of arteries with
fat researchers made a meal known as the
682 special 10 kilograms of rotten mead
and sharpened bone splinters 10 liters
of rancid mayonnaise 1 liter of
potassium cyanide and 1 kilogram of
morphine hydrochloride combined into a
solid mass and transmuted by 807. when
682 consumed this disgusting meal it
appeared to collapse however when
d-class personnel were sent in again to
see whether 682 was truly out for the
count multiple holes opened up in its
body these holes fired out high-pressure
jets of blood killing the nearby
d-classes and destroying the containment
cell 682 was fine afterwards another
test failed to kill 682 it seemed that
the foundation really needed to have god
on their side so they tried to recruit
scp-343 also known as god to help them
destroy the beast however when he
entered the containment chamber he
somehow couldn't even see the beast when
researchers asked him whether he could
kill 682 god replied he's not one of
mine deal with him yourself test failed
before it even began next the foundation
recruited scp-524
a small white rabbit that can eat
literally anything including itself
without being harmed the rabbit was
released into scp-682's chamber at which
point it approached 682 and began to eat
one of its legs 682 roared in pain and
scuttled up the wall out of 524's reach
where it remained for a number of hours
at this point scp-520 seemed to become
bored and began eating its way out of
containment through a nearby wall test
failed maybe the luck of the irish was
what the foundation needed to finally
put this monster to rest they recruited
scp-1933 a fat man dressed as santa
claus whose bodily fluids consist
entirely of the alcoholic beverage known
as irish cream if enough of this man's
self-produced irish cream is fed to
something they'll find that all of their
bodily fluids have become irish cream
too killing them the foundation fed
large quantities of this irish cream to
scp-682 and it actually had an effect
causing 682 to appear intoxicated which
was a promising sign however it soon
vomited out a massive quantity of
scp-1933 bodily fluids turning the walls
of its cell into irish cream and
allowing it to escape and wreak havoc
test failed big time the foundation
recruited the help of scp-2337
an intelligent corn quake known as dr
spanko with a voice so loud it can quite
literally talk its victims to death if
it speaks to them for an extended period
of time it was sent into scp-680 chamber
to attempt to destroy the beast but 682
just told it to leave and the talkative
bird obliged by blowing away one of the
chamber walls with a yell allowing
scp-682 to breach containment again
terrible job dr spanko test failed the
foundation researchers were starting to
get a little frustrated with their lack
of progress which you can no doubt
sympathize with and they even pitch the
possibility of sending scp-682
into an alternate dimension where
perhaps it would enter into a stalemate
against its alternate self but this
pitch was shot down by the o5 council on
the grounds that it was way way way way
too risky back to the drawing board by
which we mean they literally transform
682 skin into a kind of drawing board
scp-2521
is an anomaly that manifests any time
information about it is recorded and
immediately grabs the source of the
information wrapping it in its tendrils
and taking it away with it the
foundation sought to take advantage of
this by using a laser cutter to cut this
anomalous information into
scp-682's side however this didn't have
the results they were hoping for
scp-2521 did turn up to take the
information but it only took the skin on
which the information was carved 682
survived and quickly grew back its skin
test failed again researchers suggested
tracking down scp-169
an obscenely massive underwater creature
known as the leviathan and feeding 682
to the beast however this idea was also
immediately shot down by the o5 council
if 682 did what it did best which was
surviving attacks and adding them to its
own arsenal then it might grow to the
size of scp-169
which would likely trigger an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario it simply was
not worth the risk test failed before it
even started the foundation released two
specimens of scp-939 into 682's test
chamber these voice-imitating
amnesia-inducing monsters have caused
huge damage to human targets so it was
hoped that they may be able to do
something to 682 but this hope turned
out to be misplaced both specimens
seemed extremely distressed by 682's
presence and refused to engage at all
682 did not share the same apprehension
about attacking it charged in and
brutally killed both before devouring
their corpses test failed in a very well
documented case the adorable scp-999 was
introduced into 682's test chamber the
unassailable good vibes provided by 999
as well as an intense tickle fight did
actually lead to the temporary
incapacitation of scp-682
however the otherwise wholesome incident
ended in tragedy when 682 adapted to the
good vibes and was able to release a
kind of violent laughter wave this
incapacitated much of the staff and
allowed 682 to breach containment and go
on another killing spree before being
recontained test once again
failed the next test involved scp-294
an anomalous coffee machine that can
produce any liquid typed into its keypad
foundation researchers requested scp-682
killer from the machine and were
astounded by the results during tests on
the liquid with scp-682
tissue samples the liquid was
surprisingly effective and caused the
682 tissue to decay and crumble tests on
the living creature were similarly
promising the acid in 682's tank was
temporarily lowered and one liter of
scp-682 killer was poured onto the
reptile's head causing that portion of
its flesh to immediately decay when the
acid was returned the same portion that
had the liquid poured on it dissolved
instantly test well not quite successful
but promising and requiring further
research foundation scientists believe
that if they could one day get a large
enough quantity of this liquid they
might have a viable option but until
then the tests march on for another
experiment they introduced
scp-055 into the containment chamber of
scp-682
scp-055 also known as the self-keeping
secret is a mysterious anomaly that can
only be described by what it isn't for
example we know that scp-055
is not round but that was pretty much it
now however we know something else about
scp-055 that it can't kill
scp-682 test failed but at least we know
twice as much about
scp-055 as we did before next came
scp-082 better known as fernand the
cannibal fernand was first presented a
piece of flesh from 682 but rather than
eating it he inspected it and began to
express joy that his friends still live
when introduced into 682's testing
chamber ferdinand attempted to subdue
the lizard and use it as his steed 682
expressed an intense hatred for both
ferdinand and the idea of being ridden
like a pony and the two of them engaged
in combat mobile task forces were
eventually brought in to subdue both
subjects in a debrief interview both
hinted that they shared history prior to
containment but 682 was reluctant to
talk about it further test entertaining
but still a failure researchers were
becoming extremely frustrated with
scp-682's unwillingness to die so they
called in an scp who responded to reason
much better
scp-049 the plague doctor this sinister
surgeon can kill with a touch and the
foundation hoped that his abilities
would extend to 682 however the result
was a dud the plague doctor did touch
682 but it experienced no adverse
effects and eventually swiped at the
doctor upon leaving 049 reported feeling
emotionally disturbed by his encounter
with scp-682
yep you guessed it
test failed if it gives you any
indication of just how desperate the
researchers were at this point dr graham
pondered whether introducing 682 to a
human with just as pessimistic and
misanthropic feelings as itself would
somehow pacify it they sent in a
particularly nasty d-class and the two
spoke fascinatingly 682 didn't attempt
to harm this d-class they just shared
their profane and bleak sentiments about
the human race with one another however
some of 682's opinions were a little too
spicy for this d-class after listening
to the reptile speak for 20 minutes the
d-class fell into a catatonic state from
the sheer depression of it all he died
not long after one researcher suggested
perhaps the worst idea of all letting
scp-682 out into the wild not even
really to terminate it just to see what
it does the scientists figured there
would be some merit in analyzing the
creature's behavior this idea was
submitted anonymously of course it seems
even the most sadistic of researchers
know better than to put their name on an
idea like that as you can probably guess
this request was shot down by the o5
council the note attached to the request
by one of its members summed it up best
i'll tell you what it will do it'll go
out for a nice stroll murder a few
innocent people go fishing slaughter a
few more innocent people start up a tech
company eat a few more innocent people
go on a vacation to florida dismember a
few more innocent people i swear when i
find out who wrote this you can
personally enter 682's containment
chamber to analyze him yourself this has
been far from an exhaustive account of
all the different ways the scp
foundation has tried to terminate
scp-682 but it shouldn't be surprising
that all of their ideas have either been
failures or were too risky to even try
sadly for the scp foundation and the
human race it's likely we'll be dealing
with scp-682
for a long time to come but do you have
an idea for how you think 682 could
finally be killed something that even
the foundation hasn't thought of to try
let us know in the comments in june of
1985 mark johnson and his wife of 10
years sophie were on vacation in myrtle
beach having a great time while they
relaxed on the sand sophie decided to
take a picture of her husband for their
scrapbook so she pulled out the polaroid
super color 645 that she'd bought
specifically for the trip she pressed
the button waiting for the picture to
print pulled it out and shook it what
she expected to see was a shot of mark
lying on his beach towel what she got
was a picture of her husband in the arms
of his secretary they say that a picture
speaks a thousand words but this
particular camera takes pictures that
are worth even more than that when
developed the pictures taken with this
normal-looking polaroid camera reveal
the innermost desires of the person
being photographed welcome to the story
of
scp-978 the desire camera the main
reason the foundation keeps
scp-978 under wraps is due to its use as
an easy form of blackmail all anyone
with access to the camera would have to
do is snap a few covert photos and
they'd have instant dirt on the world's
most powerful people to further stop
this camera from falling into the wrong
hands the containment guidelines
strictly forbid the use of the camera
for anything other than simple
documentation and all uses of it must be
thoroughly logged and checked so now
that you know what the camera does it's
time to look at what kinds of strange
and mysterious photos it's taken after
all who doesn't want a chance to gain
insight into the minds of the
foundation's most famous and dangerous
inmates first to serve as a control the
team took a photo of a blue office chair
no change was recorded proving that the
camera didn't work on non-anomalous
inanimate objects some of the earliest
tests of the camera were the photos that
the research team took of each other one
by one the doctors and their assistants
were photographed in neutral poses
smiling as if for a completely normal
photo then they waited while the photos
developed like normal polaroids most of
the research team had minimal changes in
their photos one was shown slouched in
his chair drinking from a flask one was
shown in her civilian clothes getting
ready to go home from work one doctor
was in the exact same pose but with a
different colored tie on the last
assistant photographed however had their
picture come out wildly different than
how they were posed their desire
revealed by the camera was so shocking
that it had to be redacted and the
assistant was placed on temporary
psychiatric leave following this first
successful test the doctor in charge of
the project ordered a second round of
tests to be conducted this time on a
series of d-class personnel a picture of
one d-class who was photographed while
eating in the cafeteria showed up as
scuba diving on vacation with his wife
and child he was allowed to keep the
picture afterwards another had a similar
result he was photographed in a neutral
pose like the members of the research
team had been and when the picture
developed the d-class was seen holding a
smiling baby whom he identified as his
one-year-old daughter after that the
results of the scp-978 test started to
get a little
well
weird a notoriously twisted d-class
known as 7294 was photographed in his
cell and when the polaroid developed he
was in the same cell playing a cello
made out of a dismembered mannequin
d-217-017 was a late-stage victim of
scp-2
a virus that turns organic matter into
metal you would assume that her
innermost desire would be to be cured of
her disease but when she was
photographed in her cell the resulting
polaroid showed her completely made of
metal kneeling and praying at the base
of a black obelisk one d-class who had
been rendered comatose and was on life
support was photographed in their
hospital room their picture showed them
as only a limp deflated skin in their
photo the photograph of another d-class
who had become increasingly listless and
apathetic since their integration into
the d-class program resulted in a
picture that was exactly the same as
they appeared in reality except the
light in their cell was slightly dimmer
intrigued by these results the research
team wanted to see how the camera would
react to scp-148
a type of metal that blocks the psychic
properties of other scps a helmet was
made from the material and placed on a
d-class who was given an adult magazine
to read while his photo was taken when
the photo was developed it was extremely
blurry upon close analysis the figure of
the d-class reading the magazine could
still be made out and around him the
faint images of several nude people
could be seen the research team wanted
to see if the results were the same when
the camera was used on animals photos of
the lab mice and rabbits showed them
eating or mating in their respective
polaroids a zebra finch was shown
escaping its cage while a guard dog and
its handler were shown playing fetch in
the park when cockroaches were
photographed there was no difference
visible between the picture and reality
but the most exciting test results came
when the camera was tested on other scps
for a few of the scps tested there was
no visible difference between the
picture and reality this was the case
for
scp-173 the sculpture
scp-343 nicknamed god scp-014
an immortal man who is over time being
turned into concrete and
scp-063 the world's best toothbrush when
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask was photographed in its glass case
the picture showed an unidentified
individual wearing the mask sitting on a
throne and surrounded by three masked
corpses the team took a picture of
scp-043
a haunted copy of the white album that
was being interrogated while on a
turntable in the picture the album was
being returned to its sleeve they then
photographed
scp-049 the plague doctor standing in a
cell in the picture the plague doctor is
hugging an unidentified small child and
surrounded by instances of scp-049-2
when they took a picture of
scp-050 a mischievous statue of a monkey
reading a book the result was
predictably playful given that scp's
history of pulling pranks the photo that
came out of the camera showed the camera
itself with another picture of itself
coming out of the developing slot
microscopic analysis revealed that this
recursive photography kept going until
the cameras and the pictures of the
other cameras were too small to see the
team next photographed scp-053
the young girl and the photo was taken
as the young girl was drawing with
crayons in her cell in the picture she
was riding through a sunny field on the
back of her friend
scp-682
scp-053 and
scp-682 were even wearing matching bows
dresses and pink nail polish when they
took a picture of
scp-096 the shy guy though the picture
showed
scp-096's cell with nothing in it
scp-085 the living 2d sketch known as
cassie was photographed tinkering with a
drawn car in the developed photo cassie
was engaged in the same activity but
both she and the car were now
three-dimensional the team took a photo
of scp-106
the old man emerging from a wall within
his cell when the photo developed it
showed the old man roaming a wheat field
near an old farmhouse from the porch of
the farmhouse an older woman is greeting
scp-106 with open arms they also took a
photo of scp-168
a sentient calculator sitting on a table
in its containment cell in the picture a
teenage boy is seen doing complex math
homework using the calculator next to
him on the table are thick textbooks
with titles like complicated math
difficult math and math you need your
calculator for the photo of
scp-261 a vending machine that dispenses
snack products from alternate universes
showed the scp in its usual hallway
almost completely buried in coins
scp-507 an otherwise normal man who
unwillingly teleports between dimensions
was photographed while eating in the
cafeteria the developed picture showed
him dressed as a foundation researcher
talking to other researchers when
scp-682 was photographed floating in its
containment tank the resulting picture
showed the scp surrounded by the corpses
of all of the foundation staff and
mauling the person who had taken the
photo a researcher's note accompanying
this photo reads well that was
predictable yes yes it was just for the
fun of it the team also tested the
camera's effects on a few other
foundation personnel they took a photo
of dr bright while he was arguing with
dr clough the picture that came out
showed a tombstone engraved with the
words jack bright resting at last the
team also took a photo of dr clef as he
stormed out in a huff following the
argument given that clap's face cannot
be photographed they were curious as to
what the results would be the picture
showed little difference compared to
reality save for the fact that cleff's
head was replaced by an image of a hand
making a rude gesture upon closer
examination of the photo the team also
realized that there was a young girl in
the background who strangely had cloven
hooves instead of feet a young
scp-166 perhaps the team then took a
photo of dr fisher holding his pet
hamster contrary to expectations the
picture revealed not dr fisher's desires
but the hamsters showing the hamsters
sleeping peacefully in its cage with dr
fisher nowhere to be seen as you can see
from these test logs the effects of the
camera are well
inconsistent with some photos showing
very immediate simple whims another
showing the subject's deepest and most
secret desires while the researchers
working with scp-978 seemed like they
had a lot of fun getting to peek into
the minds of all their co-workers and
test subjects there's no telling what
kind of pandemonium could be unleashed
if someone on the outside ever got a
chance to use it thankfully the camera
which has been classified as safe for
obvious reasons is kept securely in
security locker hj12 at site 17 which
means none of us have to worry about our
own pictures taken by the desire camera
leaking out but if someone did get the
camera out and took your picture what do
you think they'd see
the scp foundation is no stranger to
pure evil whether it's a reptile that
wants to end all life a sadistic old man
with his own tortured dimension or the
personification of death itself lurking
beyond a limestone cavern but what if
there was something even worse out there
the embodiment of chaos and cruelty
existing across multiple realities and
dimensions and what if it was coming for
us
this is the scarlet king believed by
many to be the ultimate evil behind much
of the trouble the foundation has faced
and some even speculate that fighting
him was the reason the foundation was
created in the first place but what
exactly is the scarlet king
he's known by many names almost always
including some allusion to the color red
and then a reference to royalty or power
the red shah the crimson khan pte 616
mendez ex machina the lahar raja and of
course scp-001
to name a few and like many of the
foundation's mysterious enemies stories
about his true nature and origins abound
and are often contradictory according to
the official
scp-001 files of tufto's proposal
symbology of the scarlet king has
existed in multiple cultures throughout
history with the king often depicted the
same way as a huge red demonic figure
often wearing a gold crown or other
headdress indicating royalty he shows up
looking similarly within different
cultures mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities that the
scp foundation is familiar with are
believed to be somehow connected to the
scarlet king including
scp-2317 a wooden door leading to the
realm of a being known as the devourer
who is expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the scarlet king strangely
the foundation's official file on the
scarlet king once designated his
containment class as ketter but that has
since been downgraded to safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the scarlet king still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
o5 council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the scarlet king we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it dr robert
montauk if that name feels oddly
familiar to you it's because of its
association with one of the scarlet
king's most recent attempts to enter our
reality scp-231
this scp often referred to as the brides
of the scarlet king was formed of seven
women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent in
a long line of the king's devoted cults
known as the children of the scarlet
king each of these seven unfortunate
women were impregnated with anomalous
horrors such as the infamous scp-682
and every time one of these horrors were
birthed the catastrophe occurred and the
mother died at the time dr montauk was a
prominent researcher studying this
anomaly it has six catastrophes had
already occurred pressure was mounting
to figure out a way to prevent the final
birth but as he was working on the issue
dr montauk was struck with a personal
tragedy the mysterious disappearance of
his 14 year old brother jacob in his
fear and anger montauk believed that
this must have something to do with the
scarlet king and his disciples wanting
revenge montauk proposed an idea so
horrifying that the details were never
made public a procedure known as 110
montauk to be performed on the final
bride at regular intervals however this
wasn't the end of dr montauk's fraught
relationship with the scarlet king it
was just the beginning to give you some
perspective on just how dangerous the
scarlet king is the scp foundation and
the global occult coalition decided to
put aside their differences and form a
joint effort to stamp out the children
of the scarlet king they were successful
in this mission and even managed to
capture the children's leader a
mysterious man named depeche spivak dr
montauk who became the lead researcher
on 231 and 2317 was naturally the first
choice for interviewing depeche about
the true nature of the children and of
the scarlet king
dr montauk could never be the impartial
interviewer that the scp foundation
wanted though the suspicion that the
scarlet king or the children had
something to do with the loss of his
younger brother
still lingered just beneath the surface
like a lot of cult leaders depeche was
extremely cryptic in his answers to dr
montauk's questioning he'd already heard
of the doctor from the reputation of the
horrifying montauk procedure and was
surprised to see him so calm and
courteous in person a few key facts
about the king and his cult were
revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical wanderers
library to assist in their summoning
rituals depeche also revealed that the
scarlet king is bound by three laws the
law of blood the law of concrete and the
law of howling dr montauk confused and
frustrated by depeche's secrecy had to
learn more he found an old memoir from a
former member of the children of the
scarlet king jack hirsch who had the
ability to invade the minds of people
from the past and experience what they
experienced he recounted a battle
between the scarlet king and his
followers and a group of time-traveling
turkmen warriors from
scp-3838 hearst saw both sides of the
battle from the perspective of the
children of the scarlet king their lord
ruled over them from an immense fortress
embedded in a volcano from the
perspective of the turkmen the children
were starved and beaten peasants
commanded by the king's voice in the
roaring howl of the wind montauk also
found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various scarlet
king aligned cults interestingly some of
them incorporated the use of carved scp
foundation symbols what could this mean
montauk returned again to depesh who
finally gave him the truth about the law
of blood this is the law of the scarlet
king it's defined by poverty violence
starvation hate and most of all fear
like the serfs in the middle ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the nobles to the children of the
scarlet king this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the modern age defined by empty
safety and false comfort buildings easy
to access food healthcare knowledge
technology this is everything that the
scarlet king despises but the mystery
only deepened as montauk found files
from a former foundation operative by
the name of agent de beauvoir montauk
learned that the scarlet king didn't
seem to appear until after the
foundation was created and in fact it
seemed that the greater interest the
foundation took in the scarlet king the
more powerful he became how could this
be
things were also getting stranger on a
personal level for dr montauk depeche
repeatedly pressed him about his
brother's disappearance and the montauk
procedure during the interviews little
by little it was beginning to take its
toll the question still plagued him what
was the law of howling who or what
really is the scarlet king how did he
come to be montauk's search was causing
him to act more like the children of the
scarlet king ranting about the horrors
of the modern world how all of us are
living a lie how the only honest way to
live is suffering under the dominion of
the scarlet king this philosophy is
summed up in the words of one cultist
named arya danae cartwright who said we
must learn what it is to die to be
enslaved truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
and darkness the tempest tossed refuge
of a race of fools we must kill
modernity postmodernity with all its
analysis and sneering observation there
is only one rule the rule of chaos for
humanity for life for the scarlet king
basically any time humanity tries to
exert control over the world the scarlet
king gets stronger every time they try
to understand or organize or categorize
their world the scarlet king gets
stronger as colonial and imperial powers
conquered and invaded lands like india
africa and south america and subjugated
their beliefs under western ideas the
scarlet king grew stronger montauk was
beginning to truly understand the power
of his enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
montauk slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the scarlet king's greatest enemy the
scp foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
montauk's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depeche spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the scarlet king foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depeche demanded a final interview
with montauk with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depeche congratulated
montauk for finally understanding what
he was dealing with the scarlet king
depeche told him is an idea a concept he
is a being given power through the
conflict between the old and the new
this is the law of the howling the
scarlet king's endless rage at the
direction the world and humanity has
taken the king according to depeche
hated the foundation's belief that
science and rationality was the true
path to progress the king saw this as
little more than petty arrogance the
reason montauk's procedure on the final
bride of the scarlet king was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in the
scarlet kings realm that would be all
there is
unless our world and especially the
foundation changed its course the
scarlet king's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable montauk his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the scarlet king
take his brother jacob when dipesh told
him the answer no and in response
montauk shot him dead finally bringing
an end to the children of the scarlet
king in light of his new revelations
montauk begged the o5 council to change
their ways in order to avoid letting the
scarlet king break into our reality they
refused saying montauk's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the scarlet
king they would have to take some steps
and so the o5 council of the scp
foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the scarlet king from
ketter to safe and made its description
on the official foundation files
deliberately vague the o5 council thinks
this will be enough to stop the scarlet
king's power from continuing to grow but
montauk knew it wasn't enough he had
seen the truth and he couldn't unsee it
while the foundation was going on as
normal montauk grew to despise them he
knew the scarlet king was coming he knew
that he couldn't be stopped and that our
whole reality was little more than
sitting ducks dr robert montauk is no
longer a researcher for the scp
foundation no dr robert montauk chose a
different path he's now a child of the
scarlet king a devotee of madness hate
and chaos you can't beat the scarlet
king after all and as the old adage goes
if you can't beat them
join them
meet trevor hawthorne now known as d
4651
on the outside he was an armed robber
who murdered two people during a
convenience store shootout in texas but
now since being condemned to death he's
been picked up for d-class testing by
the scp foundation now also meet junior
researcher dr julia reed an aspiring
foundation scientist with an undiagnosed
heart condition the kind of heart
condition that doesn't mix well with a
high pressure job at the scp foundation
these two woke up on the morning of
december 6 2011 completely unaware of
the fact that they were only hours away
from causing one of the most devastating
containment breaches site 19 had seen in
years many people died that day but
thankfully for everyone else
scp-131 were there to save the day when
you think of a hero you probably don't
picture a pair of little cyborgs with
one eye and the intelligence of a
household cat but this is the tale of
how two of the most unassuming anomalies
that site 19 managed to save thousands
of people from two of the site's most
dangerous inmates open your eyes and
keep them open if you so much as blink
it's all over for you how long can you
hold it difficult right now imagine
you're having a staring contest with an
entity that can kill you if you dare to
blink for even a fraction of a second or
even worse a creature that could
potentially kill hundreds or even
thousands of people if your attention
drifts from it for any amount of time
try keeping your eyes open with that
kind of crushing pressure we're talking
about two of the most deadly euclid and
ketter class anomalies out there
scp-173 the killer sculpture
a violent euclid-class entity that is
incapable of moving while being looked
at if ever it's unobserved it'll snap
the neck of anyone nearby
scp-689 known as hunter in the dark is
an equally dangerous and even more
attention-demanding statue these two
entities are beyond dangerous even
scp-682 is terrified of the killer
sculpture and researchers have been
considering the use of 689 to
potentially eliminate the hard to
destroy reptile for quite some time
their greatest concern though is whether
the 30 centimeter tall statue would
cause too much collateral damage to
foundation personnel in the process
trevor hawthorne was part of the
three-man d-class detail meant to clean
out
scp-173's containment chamber at regular
intervals while on cleaning duty two
d-classes can keep staring at the
sculpture while the other tidies up the
cell alternating turns to blink but that
morning trevor had woken up in his
containment cell with a killer migraine
and soon that migraine would be killing
far more than just him
the containment procedures in 689 cell
were also a three-person job 689 is a
small green soapstone statue of a
skeletal being sitting on a throne
believed to be some form of underworld
death deity discovered by german
archaeologists in india this is a work
of religious art that demands your
attention or you and anyone else who's
ever seen this ketter class nightmare
will suffer a horrifying fate anyone
who's ever seen the statue is infected
by its anomalous effects it must be
observed constantly or someone who's
seen it in the past will suddenly drop
dead of a severe health issue like a
stroke or multiple rupturing organs
like the god of death the statue
represents it appears on top of the dead
body of whoever it just killed if not
continually paid attention to it'll keep
hopping from person to person until it's
killed everyone who's ever looked at it
it's teleporting abilities and the fact
that it poses a threat to so many make
this a truly formidable foe it's kept in
a constantly lit cell and is observed by
two members of d-class personnel at all
times but a crucial third party in the
containment of scp-689
is a member of personnel at level 2 or
above they remain in a control room
wearing a special visor to prevent them
from ever seeing 689 and becoming
infected themselves if the containment
fails it's their job to throw the kill
switch on the d-class observers to
prevent them from becoming vectors for
infection today this job fell on dr
julia reed she was linked to the two
observers via an audio feed allowing her
to remain in constant contact with them
and she had her finger on the activation
key for a pair of explosive collars that
were around the d-class's necks little
did they know
dr reed's heart was its own time bomb
now you know what we're up against a
snap happy sculpture and a teleporting
death statue with a hit list containing
everyone who's ever glanced at it what
can scp-131 bring to the table the two
small cycloptic anomalies have only one
remarkable ability they never blink that
and a soft spot for humans these safe
class scps pose no threat to their
handlers and can even form attachments
to researchers and other staff who show
affection towards them of course forming
these bonds is discouraged by site 19's
director because it can be distracting
but that doesn't mean it doesn't happen
the two ipods known as scp-131a
and
scp-131b are identical in appearance
except for their colors a is a burnt
orange and b is a mustard yellow the two
of them appear to communicate with one
another via high-pitched squeaking
noises and also seem to have an innate
ability to detect danger occurring in
the vicinity as well as danger occurring
near individuals they've bonded with
because of their inability to cause harm
and their generally affectionate
demeanor the ipods are allowed to roam
around site 19 provided they keep out of
the way of researchers and stay out of
restricted areas they seem to pretty
much stick to the rules though check-ins
on a and b are required every hour just
to be safe as the ipods were moving
freely around the facility trevor and
another d-class maintained a visual on
the sculpture in its containment chamber
while a third man swept up the mixture
of blood and excrement staining the
concrete floors things were going fine
until trevor's migraine got the better
of him a sudden flash of intense pain
shot through his head and in a moment of
weakness he made a terrible mistake with
an audible groan of pain trevor closed
his eyes and forced his fingers to his
temples the groan had taken his fellow
observer off guard and the man's eyes
flitted over to him for a fraction of a
second but a fraction of a second is all
the sculpture needs in an instant trevor
and his fellow watcher had their necks
snapped and the third d-class was
murdered before he even had a chance to
turn around containment protocol
dictates that the door is to be sealed
behind the cleaning crew while they're
working with 173 but this time perhaps
due to complacency the guards had
neglected to reinforce the door they got
their heads twisted 180 degrees for
their trouble
scp-173 was loose mobile task forces
were dispatched to aid in the
recontainment effort as 173 began
wrecking havoc around the facility but
things were about to get even worse it
seemed like business as usual over at
the containment cell of scp-689
two d-classes observed while dr reed
dictated to them over an earpiece from
her control center however what dr reed
thought were just minor chest pains were
actually the onset of heart failure when
the two t-classes heard their supervisor
experiencing a fatal heart attack on the
other end of the line they began to
panic this meant their attention wasn't
entirely on scp-689
and they were further distracted by the
chaos
scp-173 was causing elsewhere in the
facility murdering researchers guards
and maintenance workers alike which led
to power outages the lights in 689's
containment cell shut down guards were
dispatched to execute the observers as
is protocol for 689 containment breaches
but the fact that resources were already
stretched thin by the 173 breach caused
a fatal error in judgment from a guard
posted nearby in a panic he opened the
door to find one d-class dead with the
statue perched on his body and the other
one running straight for him in blind
fear
the two collided and tumbled out into
the hall both were now infected by 689's
anomalous attention and both were now
doomed moments later the two of them
were dead the statue perched on their
bodies accidentally catching the eye of
several researchers and guards running
to deal with the 173 situation for these
two deadly anomalies it was becoming an
all-you-can-kill buffet the staff of
site 19 were now dealing with one
anomaly that needed to be looked at
constantly and another that if you even
glance at it you are effectively
infected with a fatal disease the ipods
sensing an imminent danger nearby
immediately sprung into action it would
be up to these cute harmless anomalies
to save the terrified staff during this
chaotic double containment breach in a
nearby hallway a fleeing foundation
researcher heard the crunches of her
colleague's necks breaking behind her
173 was getting closer this thing
couldn't be outrun she turned and saw
the statue standing there just 10 feet
away from her a dead researcher laying
on the ground in front of it she was
locked in a deadly staring contest with
the sculpture how long she could survive
was now dependent on how long she could
keep her eyes open and it was getting
harder by the second she could feel her
eyes drying they burned under the
ceiling lights 173 just waited this
wasn't a contest she could win in a
final moment of terror the researcher
was forced to finally close her eyes and
she waited for the crunch but it never
came instead she heard familiar
high-pitched squeaking noises she opened
her eyes crying tears of relief as she
saw scp-131a
sitting behind 173 watching it with its
constant unblinking gaze the killer
sculpture was paralyzed by a cheerful
little safe class anomaly across the
facility a similar situation had
unfolded with scp-680
the statue of death had claimed many
lives but scp-131b
had swooped in and frozen the statue in
place with its never-ending gaze soon
after a mobile task force with vision
blocking visors used advanced
echolocation technology to collect
scp-689 and return it to its containment
cell everyone who'd seen the anomaly was
as standard protocol dictates gathered
up for later termination meanwhile a
mobile task force returned the paralyze
173 back to its containment cell with a
forklift no containment breach is ever a
picnic containment breaches with
multiple dangerous anomalies are even
less so but the heroic role that scp-131
played in bringing things back under
control was indispensable after all it's
not just raw power that counts when it
comes to anomalies the only anomalous
power 131 needed to save the entire site
was its ability to keep looking when
nobody else could they're so effective
in this role that they've been seriously
considered for permanent roles as
wardens for scps like 173 and 689 and in
our opinion
they're more than qualified
being a d-class for the scp foundation
is a lot like playing russian roulette
one day you could be assigned to a
tickle fight with a friendly blob of
slime and next you're getting your
femurs broken to lure a sadistic old man
back into his containment chamber so
when d 9781 was told to simply sit in an
interrogation room and wait he really
didn't know what to think but the last
thing he probably expected to see was
when the door behind him creaked open
was for a well-dressed stranger to step
in this man wasn't like any member of
foundation staff the d-class had ever
seen he was a short caucasian man with a
receding hairline and a neat black
mustache instead of the standard lab
coat and shirt normally seen around the
facility this man wore a black waistcoat
a pair of white gloves and a wry smile
that betrayed a sinister intent he
looked like a butler and not just any
butler but the quintessential butler if
you were asked to doodle a cartoon
butler this would be the man you drew
the d-class almost laughed in sheer
confusion he had no idea that in a mere
moment he would be dead now what's the
deal jeeves he asked with a mocking half
smile but he didn't get to hear a
response the butler approached at
frightening speeds the d-class in his
last moments on earth saw the glint of
something metallic under the overhead
lights moving too fast for him to see
what it was and then felt a sharp pain
across his throat the butler was
standing beside him now still with that
rye little smile the d-class could see
now that the butler was carrying a small
buck knife dripping with red just as he
was piecing together what had happened
to him the d-class collapsed onto the
table he was sitting at his throat
expertly slit his grisly task completed
the butler gave a polite nod and exited
the room smiling at the foundation guard
standing outside who is this man why is
he dressed like this and most
importantly why is he allowed to murder
d-class personnel on foundation grounds
without consequence we can answer that
first question right now because this
isn't a man at all he's the anomalous
product of scp-662
also known as the butler's handbell
first we need to go back to the
beginning and see how this anomalous
object first fell into the hands of the
scp foundation like a lot of anomalous
objects now under the care of the
foundation its true origins remain
mysterious and it spent quite some time
underground we mean that literally by
the way it was buried with its last
owner a man whose name has since been
redacted from foundation files clutched
in this unknown man's skeletal hand it
was extremely likely that the bell might
never have been seen again but then a
petty thief and grave robber by the name
of george dixon came along and dug up
the grave a simple greedy act that has
changed a number of people's lives
forever not knowing the true value of
what he held mr dixon made his way to a
pawn shop for his payday there the store
owner made the mistake of lifting up and
ringing the bell as if on cue he heard
footsteps approaching behind him the
store owner turned and gasped he saw a
complete stranger emerging from the
stockroom behind him he was a short
well-dressed man smiling as he advanced
towards him the proprietor of the pawn
shop didn't know who this guy with the
strange outfit was but he assumed he was
an accomplice of the man in his store
and that the two were trying to rob him
he grabbed a shotgun from underneath his
counter turned to the butler and blasted
him in the chest with both barrels the
butler fell back dead and george dixon
fled the scene in a blind panic contrary
to what the owner may have believed
nothing that happened here had been
planned dixon was just as surprised as
he was to see this mysterious butler
emerge from the stockroom so what had
just happened the pawn shop owner
reported the incident to the authorities
and the butler's body was taken to the
local morgue while the silver bell ended
up in a police evidence locker later
that same night things went from a
strange bungled robbery to a full-on
anomaly attracting the attention of the
scp foundation first the butler's body
disappeared from the morgue the second
the mortician took her eyes off of it
and then reappeared now alive in the
police storage locker why because an
unwitting sergeant just so happened to
ring the little silver bell agent
bradford of the scp foundation was
promptly on the scene he pretended to be
an fbi agent and escorted the butler off
the premises claiming that this was a
notorious escape artist who was wanted
for federal crimes in several states
things didn't go as bradford planned
though when he discovered that the
butler had disappeared from his
handcuffs when no one was looking agent
bradford theorized that this had
something to do with the bell and he
confiscated it for testing later when he
rang the bell inside an scp containment
facility the butler turned up once more
he introduced himself as mr teads and
said that he would happily perform any
service that agent bradford required
despite being offered the phenomenal
power of a seemingly magical butler
bradford politely refused the offer and
instead handed the bell over to his
superiors but don't worry agent bradford
wasn't left completely empty-handed and
was given the esteemed scp foundation
pat on the back award for performing
such a professional and selfless act in
service of the foundation the superior
who ended up with the bell however
wouldn't have quite the same level of
professionalism but more on that later
the bell cataloged as scp-662
was small and made of pure silver with
no obvious anomalous elements at face
value it was a mere four centimeters
tall and two centimeters wide with a
small inscription reading forever mine
sjw researchers studying the bell also
noted that it lacked its ringer but
whenever the bell was wrong a chime
would still sound from somewhere in the
room to signal the arrival of mr deeds
the anomalous butler the object was
classified as safe and was kept in high
value storage locker 23c between uses
for experiments it's an extremely low
maintenance anomaly with the only real
requirement being a regular polish to
keep the silver from tarnishing over
time but what of mr deeds the mysterious
butler summoned every time someone rings
scp-662 the foundation needed to find
out more so he was placed under the
watchful eye of foundation researcher dr
mirth who performed the first interview
with mr deeds as you can probably expect
from such a classy servant mr deeds was
unfailingly polite during the interview
he always addressed dr mirth as sir and
was extremely accommodating within
reason mr deed's true name birthplace
and date of birth were still a mystery
to him he could only vaguely remember
that he was of english ancestry and that
during the time of his childhood the
horse and buggy were the most popular
form of transport when asked about
personal details or his past mr deeds
would often appear to become distressed
before apologizing for his inability to
remember the details the most important
piece of information that dr mirth
obtained early on in the interview was
the primary function of mr deeds he was
an entity that quite literally lived to
serve like a genie being summoned from
his lamp mr deeds would try to perform
any task that the summoner gave him
whether it was cooking dinner or robbing
banks there were certain limits to these
powers though and these limits were what
dr mirth needed to discover dr mirth
first asked for a glass of iced tea from
mr deeds the butler happily obliged and
left the room walking down the hallway
while attending agents kept their eyes
on him mr deeds continued to merely walk
however the second they looked away the
cameras observing him malfunctioned
deeds briefly disappeared and then
returned with a tray of iced tea dr
mirth remarked that it was perhaps the
best iced tea he'd ever tasted mr deeds
couldn't recall how the tea was made
though or how he obtained it dr mirth
next asked for a bar of gold at 99.98
purity and mr deeds delivered almost the
exact level of purity dr mirth asked for
from this he deduced that mr deeds can
only perform his teleportation and
manifestation abilities when he's out of
people's direct lines of sight he soon
discovered that certain requests were
off the table though dr mirth asked for
mr deeds to fetch him a blue 1963
corvette convertible mr deeds did not
immediately procure the car instead
telling the doctor that such a thing was
impossible because there were too many
impractical steps involved in getting
the vehicle dr mirth was disappointed by
this since he really wanted that car it
seemed though as mr deeds powers while
enhanced by teleportation and the
ability to manifest simple objects are
limited by things that a mostly normal
and very persistent person could
conceivably do for example on dr mirth's
orders mr deeds politely declined to
assassinate an insurgent leader in the
middle east seeing as he was too
well-guarded and very far away however
when given the command he was more than
willing to head into the next room and
murder a member of d-class with a knife
dr mirth was interested in getting a
closer look at what was going on with mr
deeds biology and so asked him to slit
his own throat with the same knife he
used to murder the d-class mr deeds
politely obliged commenting before he
did to dr mirth that had been an
absolute pleasure serving him the body
was kept within an agent's line of sight
at all time until the autopsy could be
performed just to make sure it didn't
disappear the autopsy showed that there
was nothing inherently anomalous about
the physiology of mr deeds and he would
appear as good as new the next time the
bell rang things took an even stranger
turn after that though despite it
appearing like the foundation now knew
everything they needed to know about mr
deeds and the
scp-662 bell dr mirth insisted on
performing further studies into what
exactly mr deeds was capable of for
example he requested a deep tissue
massage and found that it completely
cured his back pain dr mirth also asked
mr deeds to clean his car and found that
it was cleaned to a truly impeccable
standard during his tenure as the lead
researcher on the 662 project he also
asked to receive a haircut from mr deeds
and found out that while mr deeds
excelled at many tasks he made a pretty
bad barber he was great at laundry
though dr mirth was eventually removed
from 662 duty by the o5 council once it
became clear his research had just
become an excuse for mr deeds to do
errands and chores for him of course mr
deeds had no complaints either way
whether it's serving up delicious tea
cleaning a certain selfish researcher's
home or murdering a d-class personnel
with a buck knife one thing cannot be
denied mr deeds is one hell of a butler
he's fearless he's eccentric he's
dedicated to the scp foundation's cause
in a lot of ways he's even more like a
living legend than a regular foundation
employee his face voice gender and even
species may sometimes change but it's
impossible to miss that ornate medallion
resting against his chest that's right
today we're talking about the infamous
dr bright can you think of many other
researchers who've been cross-tested
with the dreaded scp-682
and live to tell the tale of course
there's a special advantage dr bright
possesses that most researchers don't
it's the medallion he's never seen
without and because of it dr bright
can't die how is that possible you ask
because in a sense he is that medallion
don't worry after this crash course in
all things dr bright including his
origin his present and his future you'll
be a lot less confused so who is dr jack
bright for starters he's a decorated
researcher of anomalies for the scp
foundation and unlike most other
researchers he's uniquely qualified for
the job on the grounds that he himself
is an anomaly just don't bring this up
when you're talking to him it's kind of
a sore subject beyond that who or even
what dr bright is can be a bit of a
loaded question with an answer that
depends on who and when you ask what
we're presenting to you here is one of
the more popular versions of the dr
bright story and the one most closely
adhered to by dr bright himself these
days one of our biggest challenges to
understanding dr bright is that he has
been so prolific in his exploits and
achievements within the foundation that
when telling his story it's hard to know
where to start but as the saying goes
let's begin at the beginning starting
with the bright family bright was a name
that carried a lot of weight around the
foundation even before jack bride signed
up for service his parents dr adam and
evelyn bright were both foundation
personnel his siblings were incredibly
numerous and the ones we're aware of are
tj bright michael bright claire pierce
and a nameless sister now known only as
scp-321 sadly you'll soon see that the
story of the bright family is one of
consistent tragedy and strife while the
anomalization of dr bright took hold a
little later on in his life his brother
tj was born anomalous and was designated
as
scp-590 tj had the ability to heal any
ailment with a touch with the cost being
that he took on those ailments himself
he's now used as a tool for healing at
the foundation and he's consistently
bedridden with the illnesses he takes on
dr bright induced a mental state similar
to that of a three-year-old in tj likely
in hopes of reducing the mental burden
placed on his poor brother and sadly
that burden goes far beyond healing the
illnesses of strangers when adam and
evelyn experienced a tragic stillbirth
they desperately tried to get tj to help
tj did manage to save her partially but
the result wasn't human and both he and
the daughter which came to be known as
scp-321
were taken into foundation custody
scp-321 was a highly regenerative and
stretched out abomination that seemed to
keep growing with age but adam still saw
it as his daughter and spent the rest of
his life trying to negotiate her freedom
from the foundation when his request was
denied as a researcher he climbed the
ranks to personnel director when his
request was denied there he became a
site director and then a member of the
o5 council all with the intention of
getting his daughter back but that never
happened and the rest of the council had
him assassinated for his trouble there's
no reward for sentimentality at the
foundation the other two bright siblings
are believed to be polar opposites
michael bride is one of the foundation's
best field agents known to some as agent
cowboy his dedication to the cause and
incredible aptitude at his job has led
some to speculate that he may even be on
the o5 council already claire pierce on
the other hand disagrees with the
actions of the foundation on a
fundamental level which is
understandable given the horrific things
they've done to the bright family she
defected and became a member of the
serpent's hand a fringe group dedicated
to blowing the lid on scp foundation
secrets this brings us to the man
himself dr bright the most well-known
member of this sprawling family much
like most of the rest of his family he
too entered the employment of the scp
foundation he was a junior researcher
and a relatively unremarkable one until
his fateful run-in with a certain
necklace labeled scp-9
but what is
scp-963 and how exactly did dr bright
come into contact with it it all started
in a small apartment that was raided by
the foundation due to supposed occult
activities there they found a single
body cause of death apparently from
suicide clutching the medallion that
would later be designated as scp-963
the walls in the apartment were covered
in ritualistic supernatural symbols and
a number of occult books were also found
near the deceased man's body the
foundation gathered that the man was
attempting to perform some kind of
magical ritual but had apparently failed
leading to his own demise the foundation
soon learned that the recovered
medallion appeared to be utterly
indestructible and they placed it under
the care of a junior researcher one dr
jack bright dr bright studied the
medallion for years with very little to
show for it until one fateful day when
he was tasked with transporting the
medallion to a different area of the
containment facility while dr bright was
carrying out his simple transport task
he made a simple decision that changed
the entire course of his life forever he
held the medallion in his bare hand he
also happened to be walking past the
containment chamber of scp-076-2
aka able just as a containment breach
was about to occur abel is an immortal
hyper-violent warrior who can summon
blades out of interdimensional portals
dr bright following in the tradition of
the bright family bad luck happened to
be right in the path of abel's rampage
the ensuing battle between abel and the
assembled mobile task forces and guards
resulted in the destruction of the
entire wing of the facility and dr
bright was cut down in the brawl by the
warriors supernatural blades it seemed
like the story of dr bright was short
and simple cut down in this prime in the
line of duty but a few days later as
several members of d-class personnel
were cleaning up the mess caused by the
containment breach one unlucky d-class
known as d1 113 happened upon the
medallion that dr bright had been
holding when he died he leaned over and
picked it up and instantly underwent a
sudden and drastic change in personality
d113 was now insisting that he was dr
bright and since this d-class had no
reason to even know of the recently
deceased researcher's existence he was
immediately brought in for an interview
after a brief evaluation it seemed clear
that somehow this d-class really did
have the exact mind of jack bright but
how well after some experimentation
including from dr bright himself they
found the answer the medallion's purpose
was to act as a kind of vessel for the
consciousness of the person killed
holding it its original creator had
hoped to use it as a way to attain
immortality and took his own life in
order to complete the ritual this was a
mistake though the correct way to
complete the ritual was being killed by
someone else while holding the medallion
something that had happened to dr bright
by total accident in a sense he'd been
given a second chance at life but this
came with some anomalous side effects as
it turns out coming into direct contact
with the necklace now known as scp-963-1
is a death sentence it causes your mind
to be totally wiped and replaced with
that of dr bright if the necklace is
then removed you become a lifeless husk
until the necklace is placed back onto
you if the medallion remains in contact
with its host for a period of 30 days
dr bright's consciousness becomes
permanently bonded to the body without
any contact from the medallion if the
medallion then comes into contact with
someone else even if a permanent version
of dr bright is already inhabiting
another body they too will be infused
with his consciousness that means that
if dr bright wanted to he could have
multiple versions of himself existing at
once initially the anomaly that dr
bright had become was treated with
suspicion and fear by the foundation
they were dealing with an intelligent
and now immortal consciousness capable
of replicating an unlimited number of
times in theory he could even place his
consciousness into dangerous scps and
gain even more power dr bright was
placed under strict rules like not being
able to interact with certain anomalies
and having his hosts killed and switched
at 30-day intervals to prevent him from
building replicas of himself however
this caution proved to be misplaced dr
bright was an extremely intelligent
loyal and devoted researcher for the
foundation and as a result his
restrictions were slowly lifted by the
o5 council much like his father before
him dr bright rose through the ranks
becoming both a celebrated researcher
and a director of various sites during
different periods of time while this may
seem like a win-win scenario for all
involved this is a slightly more complex
situation for dr bright himself in a
routine psychological evaluation led by
dr simon glass dr bright shared feelings
of frustration about his current
situation he felt as though he was
treated differently compared to the
other researchers and given less trust
due to a situation he didn't choose to
be in but for dr bright the
psychological effects of having been
fused to scp-963-1
actually extends far beyond workplace
frustrations and the boredom and sadness
of unasked for immortality in a
conversation with level one researcher
dr friedrich hayden bright told him that
in a sense he truly was the heart of the
foundation rather than just one small
part in it when asked to elaborate he
said that because of the gift and curse
of immortality he would go on to outlive
all the other human operatives working
for the scp foundation he would remain
with the organization for generations to
come perhaps centuries even and in that
sense would be the one constant from now
until the foundation meets its end when
all else is gone only dr bright will
remain of course this is just an
overview and we've only just scratched
the surface of dr bright's actions and
activities across the scp foundation
multiverse but for now all you need to
know is that dr bright is still out
there and he'll be carrying that doomed
name long after everyone else with it
has fallen whether that's a good or bad
thing is up to you to decide it was the
year 2000 and seven-year-old zenyat chao
was like a lot of children her age
bright but ignored she had a youthful
enthusiasm for knowledge and learning
and with the right encouragement it was
obvious she'd go on to do great things
but her parents were both working two
jobs apiece to make ends meet so outside
of school hours little zenya spent a lot
of her time alone she learned to cook
and clean for herself since it would
often be way past her bedtime when her
parents finally got home from work they
communicated largely through sticky
notes left for her on the fridge before
they left for work in the morning it
would be easy for someone like zenya to
fall through the cracks her potential
wasted and get forced into the same
endless rat race as her parents and that
probably would have happened if her
brush with scp 5094 hadn't changed the
course of her life forever like a lot of
parents who couldn't spend as much time
with their children as they'd like mr
and mrs chao gave zenya occasional gifts
as a way to try and make up for their
absence mostly they gave zenya new books
to add to her growing collection but
their two-bedroom apartment only had so
much space for books a year ago the
family had bought a new desktop computer
to share these days this would be the
answer to a lonely bookworm's prayers
but the internet was still in its
infancy back then everything changed
when her parents bought her a copy of
the miss jay's whiz kids schoolhouse
cd-rom miss jay's wizkid's schoolhouse
was never a popular program produced by
shoot the moon software in 1999 the game
sold poorly on the cd-rom market for
five years until the company filed for
bankruptcy in 2004 but that didn't
matter to zenya as far as she was
concerned receiving a copy of miss jay's
whiz kid school house was nothing short
of a miracle and she was far more right
than she knew she didn't have just any
piece of primitive educational software
on her hands xenia chao was playing with
magic after the software loaded a
cheerful figure appeared on zenya's
monitor this was miss j a stylized 2d
teacher in a low res but colorful 3d
classroom what can you learn from miss
jay well pretty much anything and xenia
as a lonely kid without many friends had
all the time in the world she spent days
on end learning from miss j and soon
zenya went from a bright child to a bona
fide child genius her largely absent
parents barely even noticed when their
child started demonstrating an advanced
knowledge of mechanical engineering and
a new found fluency in swahili and not
only did miss jay now known to zenya as
miss joyce teaches students with
supernatural effectiveness she also
seemed almost like she was alive she was
a warm calm encouraging figure who took
a genuine personal enthusiasm
in the education and happiness of her
students more than many real teachers
even but sadly not all good things last
forever when zenya turned 12 her family
bought a new computer and the old miss
jay's wizkid schoolhouse cd-rom was no
longer compatible with the new operating
system the disc gathered dust in the
closet while zenya passed through high
school and then got into a prestigious
college she received her phd several
years earlier than expected and showed
such promise in her scientific field
that a certain organization took notice
you guessed it the scp foundation the
foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks
and thanks to the tutoring from miss j
zenya chaos certainly fit the bill she
was assigned to the role of junior
researcher and little did she know she
was about to run into an old friend in
her new line of work the foundation
first discovered evidence of miss jay's
anomalous qualities while researching a
series of strange forum posts in 2012
on a thread discussing abandonware which
is software for which official support
is no longer available there were
multiple reports of a so-called living
character in an old cd-rom many of them
had owned as children seeing as the
technology to use the cd-rom was
obsolete shoot the moons had reportedly
extremely low sales for the title and
nobody on the forum had kept their copy
the foundation classified this apparent
anomaly as neutralized no problem that
was until then junior researcher zenya
chao was briefed on this particular scp
10 years later she remembered exactly
what the forum posters were talking
about and what's more she still had her
old copy at home the senior foundation
researchers were astounded an
opportunity to study this forgotten
anomaly had just fallen into their laps
and it was all thanks to their brilliant
new junior researcher zenya superiors
ordered her to bring in her copy of the
miss jay's wiz whizzkid schoolhouse
cd-rom and then
real testing began and after rigorous
examination of the software it appears
by all accounts that miss jay really is
the world's greatest teacher in spite of
the fact she's a collection of pixels on
a basic cd-rom program from the tail end
of the 90s what miss j seemed to
specialize in was intensive courses she
had the ability to make students
certifiable experts in almost any
subject through courses that can last
upwards of 30 hours and spread out over
just a few days but this isn't as
students become so enraptured and
learning that they forget accounting for
their most basic needs and experience a
decline in process story miss jay's
lesson plans account for regular
bathroom meal and even recreation breaks
for students her talents easily account
for zhenya chow's remarkable academic
success the same success that got her
picked up by the scp foundation
naturally if they had a technology on
their hands that could reliably create
experts and geniuses with seemingly no
negative consequences the foundation
knew that miss jay and what she had to
teach could be immensely valuable in
their mission to effectively secure
contain and protect other anomalies but
we're not talking about the chaos
insurgency here the foundation would
never start to use an anomaly for their
own benefit without proper testing so
that's exactly what they did their
experiments on
scp-5094 began at site 15 and after
ascertaining that miss j posed no real
threat to her students they recruited a
local elementary school to provide human
test subjects closer to miss j's
intended demographic the foundation
found that there were a few constraints
between every lesson given by miss j to
one of her students before teaching the
really mind-blowingly complex stuff she
would always begin with a basic primer
on letters colors and numbers to make
sure she and her students were all on
the same page another constant was that
all her students would refer to her as
some variation of miss jay with examples
including the names miss julie miss
jenny and miss joy one experiment was
performed on amy myers a little girl
from the third grade her academic record
showed she was a bright and eager
student but she was described by her
teachers as being especially shy amy
referred to miss j as miss janey and
asked to be given a lesson on her
favorite animal cats of course miss j
gladly obliged and gave amy a 15-hour
lesson split over the course of two days
which the foundation closely observed by
the time the lesson was completed the
results were truly astonishing amy
demonstrated knowledge of feline
behavior diet and physiology on the
level of professional animal behavioral
scientists she became upset when the
session ended and the program was
switched off having become attached to
miss jay no further anomalous effects
were reported the next subject was a
student from the second grade named
devon williams devon had a poor academic
record and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities in
the past teachers had reported devon
having real difficulty engaging with
their lessons and the foundation wanted
to see if ms jay's supernatural teaching
abilities fared any better devon chose
to be educated on the subject of trains
and was given a 15-hour course on the
subject's spread over two days devon had
no difficulty engaging with these
lessons and after their conclusion he
displayed a level of knowledge on
railway engineering comparable to a
graduate level education on the subject
devon was so engaged in his lessons that
he had to be physically removed from the
room once the course had completed
because he'd become so attached to his
new teacher the foundation was feeling
extremely optimistic about the prospect
of using miss j to train potential
recruits seeming as she seemed to be
able to teach even the most difficult
juvenile subjects however the foundation
needed to prove that miss j could be
just as effective teaching adults for
the next test they recruited d14417
a 24 year old member of d-class
personnel who described himself as a
poor student and tested poorly on
pre-screening attentiveness and focus
evaluations he was the perfect candidate
for the first adult test of miss j to
the delight of the foundation higher-ups
d-14417 excelled miss j made him a
verifiable expert in law and he was able
to pass a mock bar exam with a grade of
3 10 after his course much like the
children he felt intense sadness once
the experiment ended stating that miss j
was the best teacher he had ever had
he's since been selectively anesthetized
released and is pursuing a degree in
criminal law with his new knowledge
needless to say the foundation was
impressed the last thing they needed to
know was who exactly this miss j truly
was to do this they'd conduct an
interview
and thankfully they already had someone
who had a pre-established rapport with
the subject zenya chow when zenya began
the interview miss j recognized her
immediately she was delighted to see one
of her students go on to find such
success in her chosen field zegna
questioned miss j on what she truly was
and miss jay responded that she honestly
wasn't sure all she knew for sure was
that she was passionate about helping
lonely children who love to learn
embrace their education that's really
all there was to it and it appears she
was telling the truth so far the
foundation has found nothing that hints
at a nefarious motivation behind miss
jay's actions it would appear she truly
does just want to help children zegna
touched by the kindness that this safe
class anomaly showed her as a neglected
child and having now seen the positive
impact that she had on children like her
thanked miss j for all she'd done and
left the interview happy that there was
an scp out there who just wanted to
change people's lives for the better and
probably all of us would be a little
better off if there were more after all
this was one of the few scps who changed
a few good people's lives for the better
and all of us can probably learn
something from the kindness and patience
of miss jay it's the late 90s and an air
canada flight experiences severe
malfunctions while traveling from london
to vancouver the pilots are unable to do
anything and the plane crashes into the
woods of northern alberta the crash was
devastating only 10 of the nearly 300
people on board are alive and even
though they survived the initial
disaster their battle for life has only
just begun it's late autumn in northern
canada and there's no telling when help
will arrive if at all if the survivors
want to make it through the night they
need to find shelter and fast as they
trudge through the freezing woods the
group finds a path that looks like it
might lead them to civilization after
all if there was a path in the woods
that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pond but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird algae or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
thomas dean who had been on his way back
to his hometown of prince george british
columbia thought there was something
strangely familiar about this he
remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in alberta and hearing an
urban legend from the older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness in the northern part
of the province there was a pond full of
human blood and what made it even worse
was that some said the pond was a
gateway to hell the scp foundation was
also aware of this legend and had been
trying to pinpoint the exact source of
it for decades prior to the air canada
crash they would finally receive
definite confirmation of the blood pond
when foundation personnel intercepted a
radio transmission from a ranger station
located within the wood buffalo national
park it was the survivors of the crash
who had managed to make it through the
night and they were about to be escorted
out of the park by rangers the
foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond as at the time they were
unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had they
set up watch station epsilon 38 and put
staff on guard to deter travelers from
the area the pond was given the
designation of scp-354
and classed as euclid foundation
scientists made a number of interesting
discoveries about
scp-354 when they collected samples for
testing first the pawn was not in fact
full of blood merely an inorganic liquid
that closely resembles blood in color
and consistency second and even stranger
than the red liquid is that the pond
doesn't seem to have any definite banks
or a bottom instead the liquid in the
pond increases in density as the radius
away from the center increases the
liquid congeals at the edges becoming
more solid and blending into the
surrounding soil it also becomes thicker
as one descends deeper into the pool and
a bottom of the pond has not yet been
reached if it even exists initially the
foundation found no signs of life within
the blood pond but that would all change
at 203 pm on the day following the
opening of watch station epsilon 38 when
the science team noticed an unusual
level of activity on the pond's surface
security footage feeds showed a shape
rising out of the pond followed by a
deafening shriek after that the feed was
cut and foundation lost all
communication with watch station epsilon
38 fearing the worst a mobile task force
was dispatched to the location when they
got there all personnel at the watch
station had been killed by what could
only be described as a gigantic bat the
task force was able to neutralize the
entity and as soon as they could the
foundation moved in to increase security
around the scp creating area 354 and
installing a permanent security detail
after this point the pawn started to
regularly spit out a variety of
monstrous entities almost as if it was
reacting to the scp foundation's
increased security measures after
scp-354-1 the giant back came
scp-354-2
354-2 was an echidna-like monster the
size of a bear that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
3-5-4 the foundation neutralized this
anomaly with napalm
scp-354-3 was a floating black sphere
capable of firing deadly beams of
concentrated energy the area's head
scientist was able to hit it with a
sledgehammer causing the sphere to
malfunction and self-destruct before it
was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with
scp-354-2
this creature was a reptilian humanoid
that stood roughly 15 feet tall and was
unable to be put down with gunfire this
was the first creature from the pond to
successfully escape containment and was
only able to be neutralized when the
foundation sent in mobile task force
omega 7 also known as pandora's box the
data on pond incursions is partially
corrupted so a complete list of
creatures is not available but some of
the other monsters that came out of the
blood pond include a killer robot a set
of gigantic tentacles that drag several
d-class personnel into the pond a pair
of panther-like creatures one made of
ice and the other of magma that ignored
foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientist at the time noted i suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through o5 believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30 of our total personnel and cut 25
percent of our funding while i can only
hope that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it i worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eerily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory mission 354 alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
swanson agent turquoise agent 86 dr j
mcarthur chris simmons leroy tucker and
a pilot named martin with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first two days of the mission but at
4 30 a.m on the third day gravity
suddenly reversed for the crew of the
ship this seemed to indicate that they
were approaching the halfway point
though what would be on the other side
nobody could say on the fourth day the
ship surfaced proving definitely that
the pond was in fact some sort of portal
the crew looked out of the portholes to
see the darkness of night above them
while sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before dawn came and when the sun
finally rose
it was much larger and redder than the
earth's sun under the light of the
strange red star the crew could see that
the pond on this side was massive
compared to what they've come into more
like a large lake surrounding the lake
was sand and rocks that were covered in
a kind of moss that disappeared under
sunlight and re-grew during the night
the team left the ship and started to
explore during their time in this
strange world they found that the day
lasted just a few hours shorter than the
night meaning that whatever planet they
were on had a roughly 43-hour long
rotation as opposed to our own planets
24. the team found a number of anomalous
elements on their expedition including
razor-sharp grass that can puncture skin
and streams of liquid carbon dioxide
they heard some loud roars in the
distance once or twice but other than
that the planet was eerily silent with
seemingly no animal life and not even
wind when it rained the soil remained
dry and based on that the scientists
theorized the plants in this world were
more efficient at absorbing moisture on
the 25th day the team ran into a huge
metal wall that appeared to be
artificially constructed luckily leroy
tucker a quick thinking researcher was
able to rig a blow torch from camping
supplies and melt a hole through the
metal on the other side there was
finally wind and odd black grass that's
the extent of what is known about the
other side of the wall because the
expedition logs are heavily corrupted
after that point but we know that
whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
date a year following the discovery of
the blood pond and construction of area
354 the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
mtf theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
3-5-4 it was apparent that there had
been some kind of mutiny within the site
and that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the convoy totally
annihilated mtf theta 12 and no further
contact with the former personnel of
area 354 has been made since following
the site's detonation a new site was
constructed called simply the red pool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research and
neutralization the new site is entirely
concerned with containment the shift in
directive came as a response to the
pond's apparent reactive nature each
creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the scp file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood pawn according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the side experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to escape right
now when asked what happened when the
pump was turned on he simply explained
that it wouldn't let them this interview
confirmed the theory that the pond is
not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world but also that it's
capable of powerful but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility that the pond isn't
just blindly reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the scp foundation have only served
to annoy it and worst studies of the
pons banks have proved evidence that the
area of congealed liquid around the
perimeter of the pond has been steadily
expanding that's right the pond is
getting bigger the last thing the
foundation agent stationed at the site
said before being dragged out of the
interview and sedated was it gets bigger
and stronger every day and now we've
made it angry
they'd spent hours making the costume
the two young boys let's call them
johnny and max had always been on the
creative side sometimes they got teased
for it at school but they didn't care as
long as they had each other they could
handle anything they were best friends
maybe one day they'd build great things
together out of concrete and steel but
for now they worked with cardboard prior
projects had included building a rocket
out of cardboard in johnny's backyard
like the kind that put a man on the moon
they'd also made a box forth like no
other more a box castle really the kind
that would stand for a hundred years as
long as it didn't rain of course but all
of that felt like nothing compared to
the tunnel monster to these two young
friends it was a thing of beauty a fully
articulated cardboard monster costume
meticulously cobbled together from boxes
masking tape cardboard tubes for arms
and legs and a little twine to bring it
all together frankenstein dracula freddy
krueger those silver screen phonies were
nothing compared to the tunnel monster
they even cut out eye holes in the head
and drew the scariest snarling mouth
that they could write below the making
was over and now they were ready to play
johnny and max took the costume down to
one of their favorite places in town the
abandoned brechter construction site to
many would seem like a strange and
dangerous place for two young children
to play but for johnny and max it was
perfect after all they were the age
where they had more imagination than
sense max would be the one wearing the
costume johnny helped him put it on
piece by piece using extra masking tape
and twine where necessary to fasten all
the pieces together little by little max
became the tunnel monster the
transformation was complete and it was
finally time for the games to begin
johnny ran wielding a stick as a
defensive weapon while max gave chase he
could feel his own hot breath within the
cardboard mask it was oddly exhilarating
he gave a monstrous roar and charged
after his friend chasing him into the
child-sized pipes of an unfinished water
drainage system it was more fun than
anything they could have imagined max
really got into his role he lunged
forwards grabbing johnny with his
cardboard gauntlets and tried to drag
him back into the tunnel all while
giving low guttural growls johnny
laughed and swatted that max with his
stick like a knight wielding a sword
they ran and crawled through the tunnels
the best of friends having the best of
times making the kind of memories that
would last forever and in that sense
they were right something they made that
day would echo on forever but it
wouldn't be something they would look
back upon fondly if they weren't so busy
running through the tunnels max and
johnny might have noticed that something
was amiss they might have seen that even
though it was only 3 pm on a summer's
day the sky was beginning to darken it
may not have saved them but it might
have given them time to prepare for what
was coming max was still chasing johnny
down a pipe still fully in character as
the tunnel monster his arms extended to
grab his fleeing friend while johnny
tripped max stopped to help him up but
something was wrong when max helped
johnny stand up johnny instinctually
pushed him away as though it wasn't
actually his friend anymore max stumbled
backwards in shock and horror he could
feel something changing beneath the
cardboard he suddenly was in pain
this terrible pain like he was being
pulled apart and put back together he
started to scream it was a horrible
sound like nails on a chalkboard johnny
had to hold his ears as the screaming
got louder and louder but max couldn't
stop he was hurting too much to stop
johnny was crying he didn't know what
was happening only that his friend was
in terrible pain and that there was
seemingly nothing he could do to stop it
even max didn't know much more than that
but he thought it might have something
to do with the suit it felt like it was
full of fire ants crawling and biting it
felt like his body was full of fire ants
he needed to take the suit off before it
got any worse but he couldn't the suit
wouldn't come off he reached for the
cardboard mask and tried to tug it off
his head but it wouldn't budge he felt
like he was tugging at the skin of his
own face he could suddenly feel
everything that brushed against the
cardboard like it was connected to his
nerve endings the fear and the panic got
worse and he kept screaming it was a
deafening ear splitting scream he didn't
know it but anything electrical within a
200 meter radius was dying tvs shut off
radios fizzled out cars stopped running
nobody who didn't work for the scp
foundation would ever know why it wasn't
even 3 30 pm but the sky above looked
black as midnight max was afraid but all
he could do was cling to the familiar he
lunged forwards and grabbed johnny
pulling him into his trembling embrace
is he still max now no he doesn't think
so anymore he's something else entirely
as he held his friend max tried to dig
his fingers into the mask and tear it
off they pierced through the cardboard
tearing holes into it it was agonizing
but the mask stayed put there was no
escape he closed his eyes just for a
moment maybe it was a bad dream maybe he
could make it disappear but it didn't
disappear only he did max was no more
there was only the tunnel monster when
johnny woke up he was disoriented and
afraid he was in complete darkness but
he could feel the old metal of a rusty
railroad track beneath his feet he
didn't remember how he got there and he
didn't remember max either not his face
or even his name but that's alright max
didn't remember him either when the
terrified johnny eventually found his
way out of the old railway tunnel he'd
somehow found himself in he was rescued
by emergency services and treated for
dehydration because of the incredibly
strange circumstances of his
disappearance and reappearance over 4
000 kilometers away it was only natural
for the scp foundation to check in but
seeing as johnny had no memory of where
he was or who he was with prior to his
mysterious teleportation all they ever
did was investigate the tunnel he'd
appear in of course they didn't find a
thing the case was closed shortly
afterwards written off as a kind of
one-off spatial anomaly johnny was given
amnestic treatment and reintegrated back
into his normal life he would never
remember his encounter with the tunnel
monster but many would for decades and
decades to come there would be stories
and scattered witness accounts from all
kinds of people maintenance workers
doing electrical repairs on subway
tunnels sewer workers cleaning up
blockages in pipes road workers fixing
the asphalt in underpasses the challenge
with being an scp foundation field agent
is often separating the genuine leads
from the urban legends and spooky's
stories but the details here were all
too similar and specific after all it
would be such a strange thing to make up
a moldy old pile of cardboard boxes
getting up and running towards you but
stranger still these incidents and
encounters were occurring all over the
united states with the only
commonalities being that all of them
happened in tunnels or tunnel-like
structures the foundation didn't know if
they were dealing with one entity or
many another peculiar factor they
observed was that sometimes people who
had encounters with the tunnel monster
then themselves appear in tunnels
extremely far away from the ones in
which they first encountered it as far
as the foundation was aware besides
transporting them vast distances it
never actually harmed any of its victims
but according to one boston sewer worker
gus segrelia when the tunnel monster
laid its cardboard hand on him he felt
the most profound sense of paranoia and
dread he described it as feeling like a
thousand eyes in the dark watching you
die then he blinked and he woke up in an
arizona viaduct roughly six hours later
everyone who reported a similar
experience with the tunnel monster was
detained debriefed and given amnestics
by the foundation eventually they
gathered enough data on fire encounters
to accurately predict the next tunnel
that the tunnel monster would manifest
inside a new mobile task force was
formed to secure the creature mtf new 4
also known as the box cutters what they
didn't expect was that when they finally
engaged the beast was that it was no
larger than a human child it wasn't some
huge tunnel dwelling nightmare even
after all these decades the tunnel
monster was little more than a
frightened lonely little boy he growled
attempting and failing to come off as
intimidating to these hardcore mtf
members and referred to himself as the
tunnel monster when they didn't react
with fear and surprise like the others
he became subdued they were able to
peacefully apprehend him and take him
back to site 54 for testing and
containment preliminary x-rays found
that the cardboard costume hadn't just
fused with the boy it had completely
transformed him on the inside he was
filled with crude cardboard copies of
all the major internal organs with his
blood vessels and nerve endings made out
of colored pieces of string they
couldn't find any information on who the
boy was if he had ever been a boy at all
and he was given the designation
scp-3663 in order to find out more one
of the leading researchers on the
scp-3663 case researcher doyle decided
to conduct an interview with the tunnel
monster it had been the only interview
with the creature to date due to the
emotional distress it caused the
creature when asked about its identity
it replied with only the tunnel monster
when asked why it attacked and
teleported people to different locations
the creature replied the tunnel monster
captures people that's me i'm the tunnel
monster i capture people and take them
into the tunnels where i live in the
tunnels the pipes i'm the tunnel monster
as the interview progressed the tunnel
monster became increasingly upset until
it began weeping through its cardboard
face finally culminating with its crying
out between sobs please
i don't want to play anymore
scp-3663 only feels comfortable in
tunnels and will teleport away in
distress if confined anywhere else as
such its containment chamber is
technically the maintenance tunnels
underneath site 54 where it seems to
have made a home for itself occasionally
if it experiences fear damage or stress
it may demanifest and appear in tunnels
elsewhere at that point the box cutters
are deployed to collect 3663 once again
and bring him back to site 54. so far
there has only been one major
containment breach with scp-3663
but it was a little more deadly than you
might expect for a boy-sized creature
made of cardboard the tunnel monster
escaped from the site-54 tunnels and
began wailing in pain it went positively
berserk attacking surrounding staff and
trashing parts of the facility anyone
who heard the whales of the tunnel
monster reported becoming extremely
psychologically disturbed by them during
this 4-hour rampage the monster also
tried multiple times to destroy itself
with various implements but was
unsuccessful after
scp-3663 was recontained two deceased
members of personnel were recovered from
the scene autopsy showed the cause of
death was a buildup of paper residue and
wood pulp in all of their major blood
vessels as well as sinuses ear tubes and
the majority of the digestive and
respiratory systems a number of other
staff members were found to have been
affected to a lesser degree but are
expected to make full recoveries what
triggered this explosive and deadly
outburst not even the tunnel monster
itself knew the answer to this question
but we do at exactly the same time a 79
year old man passed away from natural
causes after what seemed like a
thoroughly unremarkable life that man's
name was johnny
a swarm of bloodthirsty entities waits
outside the protective boundary that
surrounds the solar system they surge
through the vacuum of space looking for
vulnerabilities in the force field that
protects us from their destructive
powers the creatures ran themselves
against the barrier again and again
trying to break through upon impact the
force field shimmers a golden color and
displays a series of thumaturgical
symbols but it holds
suddenly something flies through the
protective shield from inside the solar
system it leaves a hole two creatures
enter our solar system before the shield
closes
this may be the end for humanity the
sixth overseer sits at a computer
terminal massaging the bridge of his
nose he is just logged into the
foundation database to gather
information on an anomaly whose
intentions are still unknown the o5
council wants him to vote on an extreme
measure but he requires more information
first there is something coming he can
feel it and he thinks it has something
to do with
scp-1548 05-6 straightens his back and
sits up in his chair he logs back into
the foundation database and brings up
the entry for scp-1548
he knows that this scp has been
connected to some odd occurrences
recently but what are its true
intentions is scp-1548 trying to help
save the universe or is it a malicious
entity hell bent on destroying it
05-6 must find out he scrolls through
the first few entries
scp-1548 itself is a series of solar
phenomena that occur at the south pole
of the sun
during these events the sun's plasma
morphs into different thaumaturgical
symbols each symbol is tens of thousands
of miles across the symbols themselves
have not all been classified by the
foundation yet but there are three that
have been observed multiple times the
first is an unnamed symbol that when
inscribed on a telescopic device by a
person with thumaturgical abilities can
identify psionic entities with malicious
intents the second symbol is known as
the calfastian isle which when displayed
on a material strengthens it immensely
and gives it the ability to absorb
kinetic and electromagnetic energy the
final symbol is the 12 holy owls of
cyrinthium when this symbol is affixed
to an object any entity that is killed
by it will immediately annihilate and
take everything in its radius with it
05-6 shots a note on the pad of papers
sitting on his desk he has seen some of
these symbols before they are connected
to the ortufin mythology the
practitioners of this religion are known
as the church of the second heitoth and
are a mix of human and alien entities
whose main purpose is to aid the
guardian deity of the universe
rakmuliosen in combating any threat that
may try to wipe out this existence there
must be a connection between the church
of the second high toth and scp-1548
05-6 thinks he scrolls back through the
scp-1548 file to the entry logged on may
17 1983 the first time an event
connected to
scp-1548 was recorded a pro picked up
the manifestation of thaumaturgic
symbols on the south pole of the sun it
was odd but nothing other than the
manifestation of the symbols seemed to
occur this event was recorded as
extranormal event 9008 and logged into
the scp database the event was all but
forgotten until december 23 2016 when
the activity of scp-1548
really began to pick up on that day
scp-1548 began manifesting protection
symbols in rapid succession over the
next few months a dense cloud of ionized
gas formed around the solar system this
ionized wall of radiation surrounded the
heliopause the boundary where the sun's
radiation gives way to the vacuum of
space over time this cloud became
thicker until no light from outside of
the solar system could enter foundation
censorship protocols were quickly used
to disseminate false data suggesting
that the solar system was passing
through a dense cloud of cosmic dust and
that was what was altering the night sky
and causing the stars to disappear but
as o5-6 continues to scan the files he
knows what the true cause of this
phenomenon is it must be
scp-1548 but why is the anomaly trying
to protect us from something outside of
our solar system or is it trying to trap
humanity within with no means of escape
05-6 stands up and stretches ah that's
enough for today he says out loud to the
empty room he walks towards the door and
reaches for the handle all of a sudden
sirens start going off and red lights
begin to flash o5-6 spins around and
runs back to the computer terminal an
emergency alert begins coming through
the falcon light 5 rocket that launched
earlier in the day to bring supplies to
the international space station has
spontaneously lost 50 percent of its
mass mid-flight 05-6 frantically begins
typing he brings up videos from
surveillance satellites the overseer
watches in horror as pieces of debris
and bodies of the crew flow through the
silence of space the rocket looks like
it has been cut directly down the middle
and half of the structure has vanished
from existence what is happening
suddenly another alert comes in all
communication has been lost with the
international space station without
warning the space station begins
broadcasting a series of cognito hazards
o5-6 quickly changes the channel to stop
the signal from transmitting through his
computer reports start coming in from
around the world that anyone who
continued listening to the cognitohazard
signals began entering trances then
their brain completely evaporated from
their skulls there is a surge of
thermateurgic particles in orbit around
the earth o5-6 traces the particles back
to their source they came from scp-1548
the signal from the iss stops abruptly
the entire space station changes course
it is on a trajectory to re-enter the
earth's atmosphere the friction and heat
will rip the space station apart 05-6
can't believe what is happening it seems
as if scp-1548 helped humanity in a way
by stopping the signals from the iss but
how can he be sure that scp-1548 wasn't
responsible for the cognito hazards in
the first place he needs more
information 05-6 searches for answers as
more anomalies connected to scp-1548
start occurring around the world during
a political demonstration in berlin a
thamaturgic way opens up that leads to a
pocket dimension soon after the
appearance of the portal koru arch
priest farah attainus the leader of the
church of the second off makes an
announcement he claims that the way
leads to a shelter which will protect
people from the coming doom of the
universe the people in the area along
with the members of the church of the
second high toth make their way into the
portal two undercover foundation agents
follow the group after everyone is
entered the way immediately closes and
there is no further contact what does
the church of the second high top know
that we don't 05-6 wonders he continues
monitoring the situation and looking for
answers suddenly a message comes through
all foundation channels it is coming
from the sun it is not scp-1548
instead it is scp-179
the humanoid permanently in space near
the sun 179 sends out one clear word in
its signal defend who is scp-179 talking
to 05-6 thinks what needs to be defended
is it humanity our solar system the
universe another alarm begins to go off
what now 05-6 screams he brings up the
alert the screen flashes to the moon
05-6 focuses in on where the alert is
coming from it is a foundation base
called area 32 what remains left of the
base is reporting that
scp-2821 suddenly expanded in size
formed a wormhole that led to another
region of the universe and then vanished
through it taking 38 foundation members
and 10 anomalies with it sirens continue
to go off distress signals are being
picked up on every channel it seems as
if the world is coming to an end and
everything that is happening is somehow
connected to scp-1548
a static field transmission begins
coming in from scp-3417
the words are urgent all are toughens
here all our tothens must listen now the
stars are lost static breaks up the
transmission for a few moments before it
resumes ago the first invasion occurred
the gods were unprepared never
comprehending the fragility of the
universe after its creation the worlds
must fight the transmission cuts off
everything goes silent a pulsating scp
icon appears on the screen of 05-6's
computer it is the part of the puzzle he
has been waiting for in 1999 the o5
council unanimously voted to launch a
mission called serif one to explore
beyond the heliosphere and the mission's
true purpose was to explore the
plausibility of extraterrestrial scp
objects in space the message that 05-6
just received is from serif one it is
relaying information back to earth the
video shows the barrier of ionized
radiation that
scp-1548 had created glowing orange at
the border of the heliopause
the radioactive wall seems to be made up
of complex geometric patterns around 6
000 miles across serif one accelerates
towards the barrier it smashes through
the protective shell the probe has
entered interstellar space 05-6 knows
that everything he is seeing is on a
delay as the information being sent back
by serif one needs to travel vast
distances and it takes significant time
for signals to reach earth after passing
through the ionized barrier the
connection to serif one is lost over the
next few days o5-6 tries to link the
anomalies happening in the solar system
to scp-1548
the foundation still hasn't concluded
that 1548 is harmful or trying to
protect the solar system in some way
then a message comes in from serif one
it has briefly regained communication
with the foundation most of the probe's
instruments have been destroyed but its
rear-facing camera is still broadcasting
05-6 pulls up the feed he stares at the
screen in horror as the images unfold
before him the camera captures swarms of
unknown entities surrounding the
heliopause the bodies of the entities
are asymmetrical with countless
appendages and unknown structures
jutting out from their cores they seem
to range in size from 10 kilometers to
10 000 kilometers across although some
seem so large that their size can only
be hypothesized the swarms crash into
the protective barrier that scp-1548 has
created around the solar system each
time part of the swarm rams the barrier
thousands of thalmaturgic symbols and
solar flares appear at the point of
impact two entities that are later
classified as 1548 omega 1 and 1548
omega 2 are captured entering the solar
system by serif one's camera
video from serif one shows that as the
probe exited through the protective
barrier it created a hole that remained
open for a few moments during the time
that the shield of ionized radiation was
vulnerable
1548-omega-1 and 1548-omega-2
entered through it they are now inside
the solar system
scp-1548 launches countermeasures in the
form of glowing red sigils that create
shock waves to slow down omega-1 and
omega-2
1 is shaped like an eel with five
contorted arms radiating from its body
and a mouth made of impossible geometric
shapes omega dash 2 has a tetrahedral
structure that leaves a trail of black
rocks in its wake as the two entities
move towards the sun
scp-1548 becomes more active he closes
the hole in the barrier before any other
creatures of the swarm can enter and
then launches hundreds of concentrated
blasts of thalmic energy at omega-2 the
flares vaporize the entity in seconds
the last thing the video feed of
seraph-1 captures before it cuts out is
omega-1 disappearing from view as it
creeps towards the center of the solar
system it has escaped the protective
measures of scp-1548
after the o5 council reviews the footage
they decide to deploy the scps cortana
to intercept omega-1 the orbital vessel
is fully equipped with experimental
anomalous weapons and propulsion systems
the council is sure that the cortana
will be able to destroy omega-1 data
coming in from other satellites indicate
that omega-1 has destroyed pluto and
other kuiper belt objects it is slowly
making its way to the center of the
solar system annihilating everything in
its path the cortana intercepts omega-1
near jupiter and engages the creature
after 10 minutes of battling
communication with the ship is lost
probes in the area capture footage of
the cortana and omega-1 in mid-battle
when they are suddenly surrounded by a
black substance and both vanish from
sight 05-6 and the other council members
watch in anticipation unsure of what has
just happened then the black substance
dissipates the scps cortana sits
motionless in space the entity is
nowhere to be seen a cheer erupts from
the overseers and foundation members in
the room it seems the entity has been
defeated then without warning the
cortana accelerates rapidly it is on a
collision course with mars as the ship
hurtles past one of the probes in the
asteroid belt the foundation members see
an organic mass resembling that of
omega-1 attached to the hull of the ship
the overseer council watches in horror
as the scps cortana smashes into the red
planet leaving a crater 250 miles wide
the energy released from the impact
instantly ionizes the thin atmosphere of
mars causing the surface to turn into
molten rock from the epicenter of the
impact crater a black organic mass
begins to crawl across the planet the
overseers are frozen in fear but
scp-1548 immediately deals with the
entity that is devouring the surface of
mars from the sun comes the largest
scp-1548 instance ever recorded a solar
flare is jettisoned towards mars the
impact causes a fusion reaction so
intense that for a moment mars shines as
brightly as the sun the planet explodes
its debris is cast across the solar
system over time it will create a second
asteroid belt in the orbit that mars
once inhabited the overseer council is
now convinced that the threat has been
dealt with
scp-1548 is holding the swarm at bay
outside of the solar system at least for
the moment 05-6 returns to his office he
brings up the file on
scp-1548 he is still unsure of this
scp's true intentions it seems to be
protecting humanity but why oh 5-6 sits
back in his chair and scrolls to the end
of the file there is an update to the
file by 05-3
something that wasn't there before 05-6
opens the new entry and reads the
caption all that's left of our infinite
ever expanding universe 05-6 scrolls
down the image is a picture taken by
serif one before contact was lost
forever it is a picture of all that
remains of the universe there are two
dots of light and nothing else but
blackness the swarm has destroyed
everything in the universe except for
those two faraway stars and our own
solar system which was protected by
scp-1548 but how long can it hold out
against a universe destroying force only
time will tell
think back to your childhood and ask
yourself what was the most pain you've
ever felt while growing up as we develop
our understanding of pain evolves
according to our different experiences
the older we get the injuries we
suffered as children like a scraped knee
or a bee sting rarely cause us the same
level of distress as they used to of
course when you are young and unfamiliar
with sensations of pain what you really
need in that moment straight after
you've fallen off your bike or tripped
playing soccer is someone to pick you
back up and give your sore spot a kiss
perhaps you even need a bowl of warm
soup to comfort you luckily for you
scp-348 is exactly that while many of
the anomalies held in containment by the
scp foundation have earned the euclid or
infamous ketter class designations
scp-348 is one of the few considered to
be safe both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
eldritch abomination from another
dimension spreading its influence in our
world through mimetic stimuli nor is it
a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the garden of eden to put it simply
scp-348
is a bull a white ceramic bowl the kind
you would find almost anywhere in the
world it may even look indistinguishable
from the one in your kitchen cabinet of
course scp-348 is hardly as ordinary as
it outwardly appears to be and it
certainly isn't the only inanimate
object that the foundation keeps safely
stored away the key thing that
differentiates scp-348 from most other
anomalies is how genuinely harmless it
is its anomalous properties do not cause
injury to any individual that interacts
with it nor does this bowl have any
adverse effects on the world around it
scp-348 cannot bend or reshape reality
it does not cause the person eating from
it to have premonitions of their own
death and using it certainly does not
manifest a contract making entity at the
opposite side of the table so what makes
this bowl in any way anomalous what
about it categorizes it as an scp and
not just a harmless piece of fine
crockery well why don't we start with
how scp-348 was first discovered some
time ago the scp foundation was made
aware of rumors surrounding a child
living in an unknown part of the world
according to the intelligence gathered
by the foundation this child seemed to
possess some sort of healing ability or
at least this is what rumors suggested
upon further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as
scp-348 this is not to say that the bowl
has any inherently supernatural healing
properties and it doesn't impart any
regenerative power to those that eat
from it either it does heal in a certain
sense but not in the way you're probably
imagining when the scp foundation
recovered scp-348
there were no markings on it indicating
where the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand-painted around both the inside and
outside of
scp-348 the ceramic surface also bore
the chinese letters shangshini which
translates to the phrase thinking of you
the child that first discovered it found
the ceramic bowl in the attic of their
home the child's parents were both
full-time workers and seemed to be
somewhat neglectful of their child
although they refused to comment on this
but according to the findings of the scp
foundation the child had come to rely on
scp-315
deciding to further investigate the
anomalous properties of scp-348
the foundation began testing it given
that the child who first discovered the
bull had relied upon it tests involve
foundation researchers presenting
certain children to scp-348 and
observing the results so was this bull
haunted perhaps harboring some malicious
spirit or entity that sought to corrupt
these children maybe even healing them
in order to somehow use them as a vessel
to break into our world no and while may
have not healed in any overt or expected
way it did heal in at least a
metaphorical sense if presented with an
injured child sporting any form of minor
ailments such as a cut or a runny nose
scp-348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you
may ask well that seems to vary
sometimes it is tomato soup other times
it might be chicken noodle soup while
the ingredients used in the soups are
often different there are notable
consistencies to how scp-348 heals if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered bowl then scp-348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finishing the entire bowl
when permitted to by research staff many
of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from
scp-348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claimed that even
though they were in a room all alone
they didn't feel lonely when they were
eating the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that is just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on scp-348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bowl refills with more
soup one test of scp-348 saw a little
girl age 8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a background screening made by
research personnel the girl lived with
her biological parents and apparently
had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when scp-348
filled with soup for her the girl took
almost half an hour to finish eating and
afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she ate by the
end of the meal this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal
in this instance no message appeared
within the bowl another child was
brought in to continue the testing of
scp-348
this time a boy of 10. unlike the
previous test this boy was not on good
terms with his parents and often argued
with them at the time of testing the boy
had sustained several minor bruises the
result of a small accident that occurred
while the boy had been out riding his
bike
much like the little girl this subject
ate the suit that scp-348 presented him
with this time though the bull offered a
message to the boy the lettering found
on the ceramic surface of scp-348 simply
read don't forget to brush messages also
appeared when an 11 year old boy with a
slight cold ate soup from the bowl this
child had been adopted by a foster
family and after eating from scp-348 he
saw the message i'm glad you're happy
appear another young test subject a boy
age six had a similar experience in this
instance the child had several scrapes
and scratches from playing with his
friends his parents had divorced and he
was living with his mother at the time
of testing this time
scp-348's message to this boy read i'm
sorry son a seven-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before
scp-348 she had lost her father to a
traffic accident some time before
testing commenced and received the
message i love you after finishing her
soup further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from scp-348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
scp-348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seem to be faded not the clear
hand-painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of scp-348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
with some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of this woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some career training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the scp-348 testing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became
estranged from her parents over the
years but unlike the previous test this
woman had taken it upon herself to not
only send money to her parents but also
arranged senior care for both as well
prior to testing her father had died
peacefully of natural causes after
spending his last days in the care that
this woman had paid for as the woman ate
the soup from the bowl she remarked
about its apparently bitter taste but
also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank
you appeared within
scp-348 one other adult subject that
produced a noticeable result from
scp-348 was a 40 year old male the
results of this test appeared to be the
most distinctly different from any
previous adult or child by now
researchers working for the scp
foundation had determined that familial
history seemed to play an important role
in the outcome of any interaction with
scp-348
and this individual was certainly
different to most the man in question
had murdered his father roughly a year
before the testing took place he began
the test with scp-348 while afflicted
with aches in his back after one taste
of the soup that appeared in the bowl
before him the murderer was immediately
repulsed he complained about the taste
refusing to eat any more from scp-348
shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but scp-348 immediately filled with
salt water which took three hours to
disappear from the ball despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the scp
foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in
scp-348
some are theorized because of the family
histories of some children and adults
tested that the words somehow come from
the father of whoever eats the soup
since even when a subject's father is
alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of scp-348
to provide comfort to small children
dealing with pain both inside and out
after all isn't providing comfort what a
good bowl of soup anomalous or not is
best at it's a natural instinct in many
species to protect their young and
sometimes it's not just their own babies
but any young that look like them
regardless of your personal feelings on
humans earliest stage it is a scientific
fact that human babies are designed to
emphasize their own adorable
helplessness to make sure that other
older humans take care of them a baby's
cry is an inherently distressing sound
and when we hear it some deep primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and
care for the child until the sound stops
but of course we're talking about the
world of the scp foundation here where
there are bunnies that can eat anything
teddy bears that might steal your organs
to make duplicates of themselves and
chocolate fountains filled with
trillions of murderous insects nothing
is what it seems here and even the most
innocent and cute creatures may be
hiding a deadly secret
scp-734 being no exception today we're
talking about the baby this anomaly
proves that dangerous things can come in
small packages but where others only saw
misery and death the scp foundation saw
a certain potential our story begins in
the maternity ward of a hospital in the
usa where every medical professional's
worst nightmare was unfolding an unknown
but incredibly fast-acting flesh-eating
pathogen seemed to be running rampant
across the hospital's population it
began when patients who weren't even
admitted for dermatological issues
started complaining of severe itches and
extreme skin pain some nurses and
doctors in the maternity ward began to
experience similar symptoms as well as
one of the infants leading to a massive
quarantine effort while the initial
symptoms first appeared to be limited to
severe pain and discomfort on isolated
parts of the skin the condition of the
afflicted soon escalated their skin
began to messily flake off as the cells
comprising it lost physical cohesion and
died it was a kind of strange anomalous
rot that seemed to work inwards first
destroying the integrity of the outer
layer of skin and then caused further
disintegration to deeper parts of the
body once the skin had shut off the
pathogen would turn its attention to
what was lying beneath against all odds
the disease affected organs muscle
tissue the vascular system and even
bones
nothing was spared the victims bodies
would completely break down and they
would be dead within a few hours by the
time the pathogen had finished ravaging
its victims what was left didn't even
look human anymore not only patients but
doctors and nurses that had been walking
the wards mere hours before were now
little more than piles of human tissue
sitting in what had previously been
their hospital beds whatever this was it
seemed like the fastest progressing
infection in recorded history hospital
staff and administrators were terrified
this appeared to be an entirely new
disease with a mysterious form of
transmission and worst of all no cure
they were even more confused when
several black vans pulled up outside the
hospital and mysterious men in hazmat
suit spilled out and began setting up a
quarantine zone around the entire
building whoever these strange people
were they definitely weren't the cdc
little did the hospital personnel know
that this was the group you'd never want
showing up and putting your location on
lockdown it was the scp foundation the
infected remains of the victims were
taken away for research purposes and the
foundation operatives immediately began
conducting debriefing interviews with
witnesses they soon determined from a
mix of eyewitness accounts and hospital
surveillance footage that everyone
infected with the mysterious pathogen
had all been in a particular section of
the maternity ward earlier in the day
and when the operatives investigated
this area they found another strange
detail an infant had no registered
mother present in the hospital the
foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby's mother was
the first victim of the deadly disease
after eliminating all other possible
options it seemed that the only
anomalous element that could have caused
all of this was the mysterious baby
though just how the mother even survived
carrying the baby to term was a mystery
in and of itself the baby was a
caucasian male human infant between
seven and eight months of age nothing
appeared outwardly anomalous about the
child but they could confirm that every
single victim of the anomalous pathogen
had come into physical contact with the
child earlier that day everyone who had
been at the hospital was given amnestic
treatment and the foundation constructed
plausible cover stories for the deaths
that had occurred that day like so many
others before it the child was secured
and spirited away to the nearest
applicable foundation containment site
there was reclassified scp-734
and finally the real testing into what
precisely this infant was capable of
could begin physiologically scp-734
appeared mostly non-anomalous the infant
had above average intelligence and
physical aptitude for a child his age
but otherwise showed no mutations or
abnormalities that would suggest a
divergence from typical human biology
despite a vast array of tests performed
by the foundation into essentially every
aspect of 734's biology they couldn't
find anything that hinted at the origin
of the mysterious pathogen but through
some trial and extremely costly error
the foundation was able to learn more
about how exactly the pathogen worked
the only vector for transmission seemed
to be direct contact with the baby
itself up to and including the fluids
and residues it leaves behind those
affected cannot transmit the anomalous
flaking effect to others meaning the
risk of an epidemic is relievingly
minimal but of course accidents still
happen as was discovered when one agent
misplaced her sympathy for the baby and
decided to remove her mask while
interacting with him her logic was that
her masked face might have caused the
baby some kind of distress and as long
as she was only coming into contact with
him via her own gloved hands everything
would be fine but some dust particles
were floating in the air at the time and
scp-734
sneezed in her face the agent began
screaming in pain and recoiling from the
baby but it was already too late her
fate was sealed she was taken to the
infirmary and given sedatives so that
she could hopefully die in as little
pain as possible in roughly 72 percent
of cases amputation of the affected
areas has prevented the entire body from
succumbing to the anomalous effects of
scp-734 but this isn't exactly feasible
where the point of contact is the
victim's head within hours the agent's
flesh had flaked off her face leaving
her looking like a red bloody skull a
few hours after that she didn't have a
head at all throughout the
disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent the foundation took
grisly photographs these photographs are
shown to anyone preparing to work on the
scp-734 research project to teach them a
hard lesson on the importance of
adhering to proper safety protocols and
these protocols about how to deal with
the baby are incredibly tight given that
even incidental contact is often a death
sentence anyone entering the baby's
containment chamber needs to wear
contained atmosphere hazmat suits anyone
who makes physical contact with the baby
even when suited up is immediately
removed from the area and subject to
several hours of quarantine and
observation even inanimate objects that
have been inside the containment chamber
need to be thoroughly sterilized before
being removed given that even anomalous
children like scp-734 have very delicate
needs a handler is always standing by in
full hazmat gear to take care of the
baby these handlers are rotated every
hour to maintain alertness and safety
these handlers feed and change
scp-734 regularly and sometimes even
provide toys that have been approved by
the o5 council the foundation has gone
to great lengths to keep
scp-734 alive and comfortable because
they believe that scp-734 could be an
important asset for them in the future
or more specifically they see great
strategic value in
scp-734's blood as mentioned earlier
contact with any matter from scp-734
triggers its deadly anomalous effects
including bodily fluids like blood but
unlike many toxic pathogens in this case
there is no risk of the infection
getting out of control since the
infected do not become vectors for
transmission because of this the blood
of scp-734 can act as a powerful weapon
for both terminating anomalies deemed
unviable by the o5 council and
assassinating dangerous people who
belong to rival groups contact with the
blood would completely destroy the
target's body with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly
conducted the hit
scp-734 has been fitted with an arterial
catheter so that the foundation can
collect large quantities of blood from
the anomalous infant every single week
for storage and research but it isn't
just the blood that the foundation sees
potential in
scp-734 himself has scored incredibly
well on the esslinger loyalty index the
test the foundation uses to judge the
loyalty of potential applicants to the
foundation cause as scp-734 matures if
these scores remain consistent he will
likely be trained to become a foundation
field agent in the future an agent
capable of killing someone with a touch
would needless to say be an asset to
certain covert missions that the
foundation would probably prefer to keep
off the books of course the scp
foundation recruiting certain compliant
anomalies to perform missions for them
is far from unprecedented the most
infamous of these is
scp-076 also known as abel a
supernatural eternally resurrecting
swordsman and perhaps one of the finest
warriors who ever lived the foundation
took note of this and channeled his
eternal thirst for battle into working
with his very own mobile task force
he could assist in missions by taking
out his bloodlust on enemy groups of
interest and dangerous anomalies however
this ended up working a little too well
and led to disaster abel was so good at
his job that he burned through all of
his allotted missions at astonishing
speed left with nothing more to do abel
got antsy which led him to turning his
murderous desires on his fellow team
members and then the foundation as a
whole it was an all-out massacre before
his colleagues were finally able to kill
him and return him to containment the
failure of this initiative gave the very
idea of letting anomalies work for the
foundation in the field a bad name but
since then things have changed
especially with the establishment of mtf
alpha 9 aka last hope a new mobile task
force formed entirely of anomalous
individuals and their handlers these
consist of somewhat more stable
anomalies such as abel's counterpart
scp-073
also known as kane kane cannot be harmed
with any harm befalling him simply being
mirrored back on his attacker and his
vast array of knowledge makes him an
incredibly useful intelligent asset
another of the several members of last
hope is iris also known as
scp-105 much like kane iris not only has
anomalous powers that make her immensely
valuable from missions in the field
she's also compliant and capable of
listening to reason unlike kane her
abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of
any location especially when taken with
her anomalous camera someday scp-735
could count himself among other
anomalous foundation agents like these
providing he continues to show promise
and doesn't develop a dislike of the
foundation as he ages since after all he
won't be a baby forever so if you ever
find yourself on the foundation's bad
side you have a good reason to be
paranoid you'll have no idea that one
day the man who's going to kill you will
approach and shake your hand with a
smile it won't be until later when you
feel that strange tingle on your palm
and feel the skin starting to flake away
that you'll realize you've been a dead
man walking for hours
mobile task force edna 84 also known by
the code name and thus upon his crucible
is on one of the strangest missions
they've ever been sent on they sit in a
darkened room beads of sweat trickling
down their brows the lights of computer
monitors shine upon their faces they're
tackling a monster that if it escapes
will literally devour all of creation it
has no fear it has no remorse and if it
isn't kept contained by edna 84 it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world
oh and did we mention it's trapped in a
minecraft server you heard us right
scp-4335 is a cognitohazardous
extra-dimensional being of pure terror
trapped inside a procedurally generated
world in the immensely popular game
minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
minecraftian there's a lot that needs
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps this truly exceptional
piece contained the foundation first
discovered
scp-4335 back in 2010 shortly after the
alpha version of minecraft was released
because of the online nature of the game
it's proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally seeing as it isn't
confined to any one physical location
shutting off the server 4335 is found in
is not an effective containment method
either as this just causes the entity to
simply hop to a different server the
foundation's greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of
minecraft and cause chaos in our world
that's why it's imperative to draft
containment procedures for
scp-4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site m1 the first official
foundation site made entirely out of
minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and anesthetized since then
elite scp foundation containment
specialists and gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for
scp-4335
site m1 is a large stone complex built
into the side of a mountain it has a
number of key features including a
supply area filled with materials vital
for
continued containment chests filled with
books that contain
scp-4335's containment procedures a few
animal farms for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about 4335
if they ever breach containment and
enter the server and of course the
actual containment chamber for
scp-4335 itself which is a little more
complicated 4335's containment chamber
is built out of several layers all made
from iron blocks the outermost cube is
75 by 75 by 75 blocks the inner cube is
55 by 55 by 55 blocks and the innermost
cube is 25 by 25 by 25 blocks creating
several levels of defense finally one
layer within all these others which
contains the anomaly proper is made from
obsidian blocks scp-4335
is bound into the center of the
containment chamber with a complex
mechanism the outermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to scp-4335
there are even contingency measures for
if
scp-4335 manages to breach containment
if escape is attempted blocks of tnt
detonate above the ceiling causing lava
to pour into the chamber at that point
mtf edna 84 are dispatched into the
server to lure 4335 back into its
containment chamber to do this they fire
a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring
scp-4335 back into the obsidian cube
taunting and insulting one of
scp-4335's many anomalous abilities is
being able to hear people through the
screen and being a proud creature it
often responds to insults by charging in
to directly engage the insulter if
scp-430 still manages to breach the
containment that has been set up for it
then they even expect that it will
likely soon hop into another server at
that point the goal will shift to
finding the monster and recontaining it
with containment procedures this complex
and extensive it shouldn't come as a
surprise that
scp-4335 rests firmly in the ketter
class what exactly is this anomalous
entity why does its containment hinge on
constantly providing it with items and
how did it end up in mojang's popular
building and survival game in the first
place
scp-4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all-black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular creepypasta figures
herobrine and the slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling
scp-4335 is an extremely delicate
process if command blocks creative mode
or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with scp-4335
the server will instantly shut down and
scp-4335 will move to a different server
scp-4335 also uses its tendrils to
destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption scp-40
grows and when it reaches sufficient
size it hops to a different server as
you can see keeping
scp-4335 contained is an uphill battle
but luckily there are two factors on the
foundation's side here the first is that
scp-4335 is immobilized while consuming
items and blocks limiting its ability to
actively escape foundation forces the
second factor is that
scp-4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around
scp-4335 it's locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when
scp-4335 begins to grow the foundation
also found that the application of ender
pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however
scp-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors 4335 is a
virgin-class multi-sensory cognito
hazard anyone viewing it without proper
training and protection may experience
distressing hallucinations
scp-4335 is also capable of telepathic
speech with people playing on its server
and as we alluded to earlier it can also
hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when
it comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but in all
devouring minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is
strange even by foundation standards mtf
edna 84 first discovered
scp-4335 and the single-player server of
minecraft user leaking heart three team
members jason yelsen richard duchamp and
shelia freemason covertly entered the
game to investigate and potentially
apprehend the creature when leaking hart
first discovered their presence on what
he thought was a private server he
quickly left a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion thankfully the trio was
still able to locate scp-4335
they discovered the creature hiding
inside a giant crater as though it had
impacted the earth at considerable speed
richard duchamp who was the leader of
the team at the time made the mistake of
looking directly at the entity in that
moment he experienced the full force of
scp-4335's cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes in the
aftermath of this incident duchamp was
taken off the case and jason yelsen was
promoted to head of the project things
were still going to get stranger yelsin
was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelsin
informed him that it's somehow fallen
into the world of minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this the entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server yelsen and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of scp-4335
they weren't hurt but they did appear
strange and incoherent after
experiencing 4335's cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment
4335 was contained shortly thereafter
once again yelsin came face to face with
his new foe eight months after being
captured 4335 granted yeltsin another
interview from containment 4335 admitted
that it almost respected yeltsin and the
rest of the foundation for figuring out
how to capture and contain it so quickly
in exchange it would give the foundation
something extremely valuable information
first it asked one question of yelsin
how does he define creation joseon
replied uh something that is built and
brought into this universe by a sapient
being using other things from this
universe
4335 agreed it went on to explain that
it came from a universe devoid of
creation a dark and unknowable place
filled with nothing but violent random
chaos its dimension existed directly
above ours and it often looked down at
us through a dimensional window
fascinated by all the creation below it
plotted and dreamed to one day
infiltrate our reality and yelsin
finally had the opportunity to ask the
magic question why
though he wasn't quite ready for the
brutal honesty of
scp-4335's reply i do not like to lie so
i will tell you now
i wish to suck it dry if the toys of
whatever force controls your universe
destroy the light destroy the earth and
destroy humanity
it reminded me
of me
a blubbering mass of intelligence and
order it sickens me in ways i cannot
comprehend
i hope you understand
scp-4335
was a connoisseur of creation and it
sought to devour all of it in this
moment yeltsin realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but yelsin didn't have time to think
4335 was about to stage another daring
escape attempt one of its tendrils
reached out and attacked yeltsin's
player character in that moment the
real-life yeltsin began to hallucinate
and panic suddenly back in the game a
series of abnormally tall slender black
figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber
around
scp-4335 it had somehow summoned new
minions into the game to assist in this
containment breach jason yelsen entered
cognitohazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affected by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
endermen and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for scp-4335
but there's only one question left why
did the entity fall into minecraft
rather than our world the file posits
the most likely answer because 4335
defines creation as elements made by
sapient beings in minecraft the most
popular game in the world at the height
of 4335's power everything that exists
is the product of code made by humans
creation is truly abundant there as for
our world in
scp-4335's extra dimensional eyes there
is no creation no intelligent design no
soothing piano soundtrack just
frightening chaotic randomness which is
too unlike its own dimension so even if
scp-4335
ever did arrive in our reality we would
likely be disappointed by how little
there is to eat
scp-682
does it even require an introduction the
scp foundation thinks this cantankerous
reptile needs a serious attitude
adjustment by which we mean they really
really want to kill it but as you might
have seen in our previous videos on the
subject they don't call this monstrosity
the hard to destroy reptile for nothing
that's why we've done what the
foundation isn't allowed to we outsource
the dirty job of squashing this lizard
to all of you we made a community post
asking for your ideas on how this scaly
abomination can finally be destroyed and
you delivered big time a truly
staggering amount with over 6 000
comments now let's see if we can finally
get our answer because believe us the
foundation is desperate at this point i
don't know what to write for a name said
the most effective way that dr bright
approves of chainsaw cannon as awesome
as a chainsaw cannon would probably be
to use it sadly wouldn't be very
effective against scp-682
chainsaws are blades and we know from
the termination test logs that blades
have been ineffective even when scp-682
is chopped up into tiny little pieces
those pieces have a nasty habit of
reforming into the big ugly monster we
all know and fear awesome cardinal said
the scp foundation could try to bring it
to the void in russia where the pattern
screamers are this was a popular idea
and the foundation actually tried this
the scp being referred to here is
scp-3930
a big old pile of nothing in russia that
causes things inside it to stop existing
when they threw scp-682 inside it
technically did stop existing despite
this it could still be perceived and
still caused the deaths of all
surrounding researchers 15 hours later
it just reappeared in its containment
chamber apparently totally fine you can
probably see why the foundation is
frustrated by this thing scorecrow and
friends said black hole need i say more
you may need to say a little more for
starters there would be logistical
issues in actually getting the creature
anywhere near a black hole but there's
also the concern that it may just adapt
its body to respond to the intense
gravity present near a black hole or
even scarier somehow adapt to reproduce
the powers of a black hole it probably
wouldn't be worth the risk of ending up
with a reptile capable of creating
gamma-ray bursts stellar solar sky said
put the reptile inside nuclear fusion
and watch its particles disappear the
foundation tried something pretty close
to this by trying to put it inside
scp-536 a chamber where they can use
dials to control the physical contents
within they increased the speed of light
and nuclear force within the chamber
which caused scp-682 to disintegrate
until all that was left was a piece of
matter one percent of its original size
however the creature then reformed and
killed the researchers later tests
showed that its body had become an
unknown form of matter held together by
quantum effects impossible to unravel
with our current understanding of
science brea fun said so you know that
coffee machine thing that is 294 type in
682 killing substance and then repeat
that until you have enough to fill its
entire room then fill it they did
actually try this and the resulting
substance was effective in damaging
scp-682's tissue however the one problem
is that it's extremely difficult to
produce enough of this stuff to actually
submerge the creature worse still if
enough was made to cause significant
damage to the body of scp-682
it may adapt to the chemical as a
defense mechanism making it ineffective
as a weapon its adaptive ability is
truly
scp-682's greatest asset when it comes
to thwarting the foundation's constant
attempts to kill it alex webb said ask
it kindly to die we don't believe that
the foundation has actually ever tried
this one but just based on the fact that
scp-682 is a huge jerk on top of being
an omnicidal monster he probably
wouldn't respond to polite requests
iflashboy said i wonder if doomslayer
could defeat the reptile he's torn
through every demon in hell and even
titans so would 682 be a challenger or
just another tuesday for the slayer
that's a slightly trickier one of course
since they exist in different universes
we'll never see an official battle
between the doom slayer and scp-682
however given that the doom slayer's
weapons are all conventional meaning
largely based around slashing crushing
shooting and blasting we don't know
whether he'd actually be able to slay
the beast that being said we don't know
if 682 could kill him either we could
have a stalemate on our hands here
amanda brennaman said i asked my sister
who's never heard of scps this question
and her answer was you hit it again
amanda your sister may be the one to
finally stop this creature getting the
two of them in the same room may be the
biggest logistical problem here samuel
pasqual said throwing him down scp-087
so he suffers and is contained once and
for all in the improbable case he is
still alive
scp-087 the endless staircase can be a
dangerous anomaly for humans who don't
know what they're getting into however
scp-682 would likely detect the threat
far earlier than any human and then
breach containment it's definitely
gotten out of stickier situations
yashashiri shara said send him to
endless ikea where he will be trapped
forever much like
scp-087 the endless ikea wouldn't pose
the same threat to scp-682 as it would
for the average human trapped inside the
staff would be no trouble for 682 and it
would be able to devote pretty much all
of its time in there to finding a way
out and when he did finally break out
he'd probably be armed with a terrifying
knowledge of how to correctly assemble a
svendinthrook we shudder at the thought
jack loss said oxygen destroyer used to
deal with another big lizard issue back
in 1954. sadly this would also likely be
an ineffective weapon against
scp-682 because the creature thrives in
anaerobic environments seeing as its
native atmosphere seems to have no
oxygen and according to foundation tests
it can survive just fine in a vacuum
whether scp-682 could take godzilla in a
fight is still up for debate and you can
argue about which lizard would reign
supreme in the comments ace goodwin said
just don't kill him let him live bro he
hasn't done anything wrong yet let him
vibe in his chamber wait a second did
scp-682 write this
moving on a lot of you said throw him
into the sun while the sun is a gigantic
nuclear furnace where hydrogen is built
into helium at a temperature of millions
of degrees there is the issue of not
only being beyond difficult to
incapacitate the creature for long
enough to get into the rocket but also
the problem of the sun being 93 million
miles away from earth it's a long trip
there no matter what and during that
time scp-682 would almost definitely
figure out a way to return to earth it
might even rewire the rocket and turn it
into its own personal vehicle giving it
the freedom to cause chaos around the
solar system and even if everything else
went well
scp-682 would still probably survive
being thrown into the sun after all the
gate guardian's flaming sword is
described as being hotter than the sun
and it didn't manage to kill the hard to
destroy reptile pokemon redboy said send
him to mars and launch a nuke that can
destroy a planet along with the scp
while a nuke capable of destroying the
planet of mars would also likely destroy
scp-682 in the process the destruction
of mars itself would likely cause such a
catastrophic shift in our neck of the
solar system that we'd probably die
along with it the question at that point
is whether it's really worth killing
ourselves to take down the lizard
artemis said let it live with 999 its
entire life and it's not a threat this
is a double-edged sword during their
cross test
scp-999 did pacify scp-682 and put it in
a state of bliss and laughter for a
brief period however this actually
resulted in a pretty catastrophic
tragedy too 682 adapted to 999's effects
and released a beam of laughter that
incapacitated everyone around it
allowing it to escape and go on a
killing spree so maybe the two are
better kept apart doctor was upset i'd
give 682 a jar of pickles to open and
the jar would be so tight that scp-682
couldn't open it and he would be so
embarrassed by it that he would just
destroy himself you may actually be on
to something here we know we'd be
extremely embarrassed if we couldn't
open the jar but there are three major
problems one where does one get such a
jar can scp-343 make a jar of pickles so
difficult to open that he himself can
open it two we don't know if scp-682
likes pickles enough to make opening the
jar an attractive prospect and three if
it does turn out that it likes pickles
it would probably just eat the jar too
shuvo batacharji said to deal with him
in my opinion send scp-682 into scp-3001
aka the red reality that's my theory
this could potentially be an effective
method of trapping scp-682 for a period
of time however the problem is that
there's no reliable way to access the
red reality the only person who's ever
really been inside is robert scranton
and he ended up there completely by
accident so this doesn't seem to be a
reliable neutralization method for
scp-682
adding to that the panel that dr
scranton was transported to the red
reality with eventually came back which
means it might only be a temporary
solution anyway mistake to society yay
said can someone ride scp-682 without
them dying this isn't technically about
neutralizing scp-682 but it deserves an
answer while it appears that some people
are able to ride 682 such as
scp-053 the little girl and 05-6 aka the
american in the orboro cycle he doesn't
seem to enjoy it at least he didn't when
scp-082 better known as ferdinand the
cannibal attempted it of course
ferdinand describes the relationship
quite differently insisting that 682 is
his bayard his magical steed laura
garcia said chop it up put the pieces in
a giant bowl with egg beaters stirring
it constantly so it can't reanimate keep
it kinetically moving so it doesn't ever
have the rest time to reform giant egg
beating machine to prevent reformation
killing it would take a rival sunblast
to stop it from reanimating itself this
has got to be one of the most creative
ones we've encountered even dr bride
probably wouldn't think to use giant
whisks on the beast however it probably
wouldn't kill the ornery creature for
good as we've said before not only has
the beast regenerated from things as hot
as the sun he's also able to remanifest
from the tiniest atoms or even nothing
at all on the plus side he may reanimate
with a new super whisking ability and
could potentially give scp 5031 a run
for best cook and containment shaked ben
yakar said i think they need to explode
him from the inside because maybe
there's one spot in this body that isn't
invincible and if they heard it scp-682
will die the problem with scp-682 isn't
necessarily that it's invincible just
hyper-adaptive and hyper-regenerative as
you may have seen in other videos
scp-682 has been shot dismembered burned
frozen vaporized blown up partially
eaten and even totally disintegrated but
it always manages to come back even from
the smallest specks of matter it would
almost be admirable if it wasn't a
perpetually aggressive murder monster
breibot said put it in 106's pocket
dimension this actually happened once
during a containment breach where the
old man as well as scp-953 the
polymorphic humanoid ended up in 682's
cell
scp-106 dragged them all into its pocket
dimension for a bit of the odd ultra
violence and when they emerged it was
clear that they'd all taken considerable
damage
scp-682 wasn't killed though and 106
hasn't tried anything like that again
since non-player cactus said trick him
into killing john wick's dog to be fair
if anyone could take this monster down
it'd probably be john wick though
scp-682 might be too smart to actually
kill his dog in the first place and if
he did manage to best john weck well we
hate to think what a 682 with the
martial prowess and gun skills of john
wick would be like actually no we don't
hate to think about it because it would
be awesome these are just a little
taster plate of the huge and varied
potential murder methods you've devised
for this terrible creature but there
were just too many good ones so we'll
have to save the rest for another day
which means it isn't too late to tell us
yours let us know your idea down in the
comments and make sure to subscribe turn
on notifications and keep an eye on our
community tab so you can be part of the
next video congratulations
you just started your new job at the scp
foundation as a junior researcher we
help you survive long enough to retire
and collect your foundation pension but
you've got a lot to learn before you can
even think about that you're here to
find out more about some of the most
mysterious entities known to man and the
foundation depends on you to do your job
right or the world might not see
tomorrow but hey no pressure you're
going to hear a lot of new terminology
on the job big scary words like apollyon
and thalmatology and of course euclid
and ketter the two most common
containment classifications today we're
going to answer a question that's been
on a lot of people's minds what do these
classifications actually mean and what's
the difference between them first it
must be noted that these classes don't
have much to do with danger as you may
think instead object classes are all
about how difficult an anomaly is to
contain and we're going to take you on a
crash course of each of them and provide
some examples so you can broaden your
idea of what exactly euclid ketter and
all the other classes of anomalies can
be of course while euclid and keter are
perhaps the best known object classes
they aren't the only ones just below
them in terms of severity is the safe
class it may be every guard in d-class's
dream to get assigned to safe scps but
this classification doesn't mean the
anomaly in question is harmless it does
mean that they are easy to contain
though often requiring very few
resources or certain specific activation
mechanisms for example
scp-507 the unwilling dimension hopper
the unwilling dimension hopper is fully
cooperative with foundation containment
protocols earning him the safe class
scp-662
the butler's handbell while capable of
extreme violence doesn't activate unless
someone rings it making it safe to store
and of course
scp-999 the tickle monster earned its
safe rating by essentially wanting to
keep foundation staff pleased at every
turn and requiring virtually nothing in
the way of containment euclid comes next
this class actually has the widest scope
of any object class under foundation
control and the grand majority of
objects fall under this banner unlike
safe class anomalies euclid anomalies
require greater resources to keep
contained the euclid classification can
also mean that containment isn't always
reliable and is often given due to
either a lack of knowledge about the
anomaly or there being some degree of
inherent unpredictability unpredictable
is really the key word when it comes to
euclid scps anomalies that are either
autonomous meaning they can move on
their own sentient meaning that they're
capable of thought or sapient meaning
they are partially intelligent almost
always automatically fall into the
euclid class this is because anything
that moves or thinks on its own is
capable of surprising and unpredictable
behavior notwithstanding certain
exceptions like the aforementioned
tickle monster this brings us to ketter
in the simplest terms you could describe
keter class anomalies as euclid but
worse again this has nothing to do with
how violent or dangerous the anomaly is
merely how difficult it is to contain
ketter class anomalies often require
extensive resources to fully contain
containment methods are also often extra
thorough and complex though when it
comes to a ketter class anomaly there's
no guarantee the methods will be 100
percent effective there are a number of
reasons an scp can slip into ketter
territory including but not limited to
extreme aggression and its frequent
escape attempts existing in large
numbers over a wide area and having
anomalous abilities that make them
particularly difficult to contain like
teleportation or the ability to walk
through walls to better explain this
foundation researchers have devised a
simple method known as the locked box
test if you were to leave an item inside
a locked box and stop supervising it and
it's still there when you get back then
the item is probably safe if you leave
an item inside a locked box without
supervision and you're not sure what
exactly will happen then it's probably
euclid if you leave an item inside a
locked box without supervision and it
easily breaks free then you likely have
a ketter object on your hands or rather
did before it broke out and ran off
before we go any further it's worth
briefly mentioning that there are two
other primary object classes that cover
most scps that aren't under the safe
euclid and ketter banners these are
thomial and neutralized thaumial
anomalies are scps that are used to
contain other scps such as scp-3000
the legendary amnestic producing
anatashia neutralized anomalies are
objects that either have lost their
anomalous qualities or been straight up
destroyed a good example being scp-1762
the cardboard box which used to contain
the land of fantasy but back to euclid
and ketter what are some good examples
of euclid and ketter class anomalies in
containment right now let's take a look
at some of the foundation's most iconic
euclid classes first kicking things off
we have scp-096
also known as the shy guy we all know
and fear this self-conscious serial
killing monster that murders anything
that sees its face as you already know
when someone sees the face of the shy
guy nothing can stand in its way on its
quest to utterly destroy them the
monster has not only proven successful
in causing mass casualty events it's
also pretty much indestructible and has
shown that it's able to tear its way out
of containment with ease so you may be
wondering why is the shy guy euclid and
not ketter well it may surprise you to
hear this
scp-096 is actually closer to safe than
ketter the monster may be incredibly
dangerous when its rage state is
activated but it's proven fairly easy
for the foundation to control this
activation the only times that 096 has
breached containment is when photographs
of its face have been found out in the
real world but as long as the foundation
can prevent people from seeing its face
it poses no real risk of containment
breach the very fact that the foundation
can't know for sure how many photos of
it are out there adds an element of
unpredictability to its containment and
that is why despite being incredibly
scary and dangerous
096 is firmly euclid next another euclid
anomaly that needs no introduction
scp-173 also known as the sculpture this
nasty piece of modern art has given
workers at the foundation many a
sleepless night thanks to its terrifying
tendency to snap the necks of anyone who
isn't looking at it this is a creature
so scary that even scp-682
feels uncomfortable around it much like
scp-096
173 has also proved nigh impossible to
kill and in a containment breach it's
been known to stack up bodies like it
was judgment day so why just euclid
rather than ketter once again it all
comes down to how the foundation
understands just how
ticks as everyone knows by now 173 is
paralyzed whenever someone is looking at
it as a result the foundation has been
able to devise containment methods that
center around keeping 173 constantly
observed the reason it's euclid rather
than safe is that while quite reliable
this method is also somewhat time and
resource intensive as with anything that
requires a high degree of human
involvement the potential for human
error is always there
and finally in our rundown of famous
euclid class objects we have
scp-3008 more broadly known as the
infinite ikea this sinister retail giant
is a pocket dimension hiding within an
ikea superstore leading to what seems to
be an infinite furniture warehouse
filled with scary faceless creatures
known as the staff hundreds or perhaps
even thousands of people have become
trapped in scp-3008
and it may even connect to other
dimensions this is one place where you
really really don't want to get stuck
while shopping for a new piece of
furniture but it's still euclid why well
because to the best of our knowledge
there's only one gateway into 3008's
pocket dimension inside our reality and
the foundation has that specific site on
lockdown while there are still things we
don't know about scp-3008
the foundation has been able to secure
and contain the entrance it's euclid
rather than safe because this entrance
still needs to be patrolled regularly to
ward off any staff attempting to escape
and prevent further victims from
entering which is a low risk but
resource heavy job next up is ketter
class first we have the terrifying
scp-682 also known as the hard to
destroy reptile anyone who's seen our
videos on this nasty creature knows that
it really really lives up to that name
682 may not be the most dangerous scp
especially with cosmic monsters like the
scarlet king and the devourer of worlds
out there but it's one of the most hardy
thanks to its incredible adaptive
abilities because of the way 682 adapts
to pretty much any threat it's virtually
impossible to attack it the same way
twice however if being violent and
indestructible was all it took to become
a ketter class anomaly the shy guy would
be right there with it there are two key
factors that push 682 into ketter
territory it's incredibly high
intelligence and the fact that it reacts
unpredictably to all external stimuli
because of its intelligence 682 is able
to actively scheme to escape containment
something it does with such regularity
that the foundation is constantly trying
to terminate it and because of its
adaptive abilities its behavior in
response to containment is often nigh
impossible to predict as a result of all
of this 682 is a complete nightmare to
keep locked up making it ketter next a
ketter class anomaly that's not quite as
well known and not nearly as ferocious
scp-3663
also known as the tunnel monster or the
cardboard box monster this entity is as
scary as it is incredibly sad he was
once a normal little boy playing in an
abandoned industrial area with his
friends he had built himself a crude
monster costume out of cardboard boxes
but through anomalous means this costume
bonded with the little boy turning his
organs into cardboard and twine now it
manifests in pipes and tunnels across
the country approaching nearby humans
and causing paranoia and fear it'll then
grab his victims and transport them
elsewhere leaving them unconscious and
afraid but otherwise unharmed clearly
we're not looking at an anomaly even
close to being as dangerous and deadly
to scp-682
but it's still very much ketter why
because the teleporting ability inherent
to
scp-3663 makes it incredibly difficult
to consistently contain along with its
inherent distrust of foundation
personnel the foundation have yet to
devise a truly effective containment
method for 3663 and its teleporting
antics so ketter class is where it
remains despite it being mostly benign
and finally scp-1000
aka bigfoot this is one of the few
anomalies that genuinely holds the moral
high ground over the foundation on
account of them formerly being an
incredibly advanced species almost wiped
out by humanity in the past now the
foundation is feeding everyone the lie
that even looking at one of these
creatures can result in death even
though it can't the reality is that the
foundation hopes to keep
scp-1000 suppressed fearing that if they
ever regained their former glory they
would surely oppress humanity just as
humanity had oppressed them even though
once again it doesn't appear that
scp-1000 has any such malicious
intentions so why are these abnormally
large and abnormally intelligent apes
cater class once again it all comes down
to two facts tipping the classification
scales and in this case those are
population and dispersion there are a
lot of these creatures out there
especially across north america and the
fact they appear in forests all across
the country makes it incredibly
difficult for the foundation to keep a
lid on them seeing as a civilian simply
seeing an scp-1000 specimen constitutes
a containment breach these happen
frequently especially if you run
encrypted and conspiracy circles and are
out actually looking to meet one that
brings us to the end of our crash course
on euclid and ketter class anomalies we
hope you enjoyed your stay and managed
to survive all the strange and horrific
entities we've covered let us know if
you've enjoyed this video in the
comments and want to see more of the ins
and outs of the scp foundation's
classification system explained but for
now you're finally ready to start your
research role at the scp foundation just
make sure you've got your last will and
testament written before your first day
have you ever seen something you weren't
supposed to something that made you feel
off
something you regret secrets like these
are best kept to yourself but since
you're still alive whatever you saw
wasn't nearly as bad as what peter
holland saw one fateful night in january
of 2015.
peter was an unremarkable man an office
worker slaving away at the daily grind
and like a lot of people peter enjoyed
nothing more than coming home after a
long hard day kicking back and watching
some tv it was this innocent activity
that led to peter's horrifying brush
with scp-5049
altering the course of his otherwise
average life forever the event started
at around 10 05 pm peter was channel
surfing glued to the couch in his
sparsely furnished apartment commercials
commercials commercials as far as
peter's tired eyes could see he paused
for a moment to watch the end of an ad
for a car he could never hope to afford
on his salary but something stopped him
from changing the channel again the next
ad had begun and it was playing a
strange scratchy jingle that gave peter
an odd sense of unease but even stranger
than that was the text on screen
demon dan's discount homunculus depot in
baby blue bubble lettering he forced a
smile this had to be some weird comedy
skit or viral marketing campaign or
maybe it was something he drank but no
this was a real commercial and things
were about to get even weirder the peppy
logo faded to a concerning site a tall
humanoid figure dressed like a used car
salesman but one that definitely wasn't
human his skin was dark green and
covered in patches of thick fur he had
long fingers with intimidating claws and
a grin full of needle-like [ __ ] it
looked almost
demonic and after a few seconds the
demon began to speak hey there folks
it's your man demon dan coming at you
with the latest and greatest deals from
demon dan's discount homunculus depot
we've just accepted a shipment of brand
new models that would make even the most
discerning customers weep with
excitement let's see what we've got the
creature apparently named demon dan
stepped away from his desk revealing two
long furry goat legs that ended in large
pointed hooves peter now assumed he
really was going crazy but at this point
he was along for the ride demon dan
continued his pitch looking to make your
way through the capitalist hellscape
that makes home look cozy come try one
of our newest businessman models dan
gestered behind him to where peter was
horrified to see a total of 52 adult
male human bodies hanging from a wall
there was something uncanny about them
they seemed almost hollow like a highly
realistic costume or a prop from a
horror movie peter didn't have much time
to think about it though as demon dan
went on if you're looking for an extra
challenge of inequality the business
woman model may be a right fit for you
the commercial then reveal the wall of
human female bodies strung up in a
similar fashion now you may be thinking
but dan business sounds hard i just want
to have some fun and the fine team here
at demon dan's discount homunculus depot
have got you covered the camera zoomed
out to show an area of the store filled
with children's decorations and more of
these strange hollowed-out human suits
in child sizes to match and who has more
fun than kids no one that's who for a
limited time the purchase of any child
size unit comes with a complimentary 50
off coupon for parental units you just
can't say no to a deal like that before
peter could process the madness that was
unfolding before him the camera cut
again the store's logo appeared on the
screen once more along with several cuts
to locations around the store itself
there were more human bodies hundreds of
them demon dan's sleazy voice rang out
over all of it here at demon dance
discount a monkey list depot we know
it's not all fun and games the bravest
among us have a mission to accomplish
the seven lords are ever planning their
invasion after all so you're looking for
function over form well we've got that
in spades down here in the tactical
services department you'll be kicking
ass in no time when you're wearing the
latest models at the best prices seven
lords invasion what did any of this mean
suddenly the camera was showing him a
new room red curtains parted revealing
more of these person suits several
bearing a striking resemblance to real
human celebrities he managed to make out
gucci mane avril lavigne paul mccartney
and britney spears before demon dan's
appearance once again drew his attention
i've got a special treat for you we're
happy to announce the vip look-alike
department we all know how difficult the
creation of homunculus is it's a fine
art that takes years of practice so when
a replacement order on vips comes in
every detail needs to be perfect
unfortunately that's not always the case
but for the right price you too can look
like famous icons from around the globe
the image of celebrity bodies faded from
view and peter was left looking at the
grinning demon dance standing behind the
front desk of his impossible store once
more he said there you have it folks
come on down to demon dance discount
homunculus depot if you're viewing the
advertisement then you've been selected
for entry please enter the nearest door
for instant deals and upgrade those old
duds for one of our newest models what
are you waiting for come on down the
logo popped up again hovering above some
bold text that said please enter the
nearest door peter had had enough he
switched off the tv what a horror show
he thought they should just warn you
before they put short horror films on tv
like that he had no idea they could just
slip them in among regular commercials
surely demon dan in his store couldn't
be real right but as his eyes drifted to
the door in his room he didn't feel
quite so certain well there was only one
way to find out peter got up went over
to the door took a deep breath and
walked through it peter holland was
never seen again not as himself anyway
the scp foundation has long been aware
of this sinister transmission known as
scp-5049-2
and luckily has found ways to prevent it
from claiming more victims the
foundation television analysis
department as well as web crawler 40y40
which is the software the foundation
uses to root out anomalous activity
online are always vigilant for signs of
demon dan's commercial running just
observing demon dan who is himself
classified as scp-5049-a
and his ads put you in immediate danger
as they can transform any nearby doors
into scp-5049-1s
those are inter-dimensional portals that
remain active for around 15 minutes
after viewing the ad so then what
specifically is
scp-5049 it's the entire pocket
dimension known as demon dan's discount
homunculus depot a kettier-class spatial
anomaly constantly on the lookout for
new human victims which it transforms
into fleshy suits for its demonic
clients which let them blend in around
humans prior to its discovery by the
foundation it's likely that demon dan
and his associates claimed hundreds if
not thousands of lives but sadly even
discovering this anomaly came at a
gruesome cost to the foundation on
february 16 2020 the ad played on safe
storage warehouse 13's break room
television at the time of the broadcast
four foundation personnel were present
including security agent william birkin
worrying that this was a potential
security threat agent birkin
investigated the door to a nearby closet
the second he opened it he was
transformed to the storefront of demon
dan's discount homunculus depot he saw
demon dan himself standing at the corner
while four smaller reptilian imps fought
over a small flesh suit demon dan
scolded them before turning his
attention to agent perkin just tis you
aren't supposed to be here little man
how naughty i'm gonna have to have a
word with marketing
once i'm through with you
agent birkin fearing for his safety drew
his weapon and shot demon dan three
times
the creature dematerialized before
appearing right next to agent birkin and
disarming him with a swift chop the
unfortunate security agent was then
grabbed by the considerably larger demon
dan and thrown over dan's shoulder we
know all of this because agent birkin's
standard issue foundation body camera
recorded the whole terrifying ordeal
even as demon dan dragged the helpless
birkin back into the twisted workshop
behind the store there birkin saw what
would soon be his own fate right before
his eyes dan's minions converting human
bodies into fleshy suits for their demon
clientele and this unfortunate security
officer was next dan gave him over to a
pair of large sheep-like demons and told
them to drain skin and declaw him
birkin's video feed finally cut as the
demons pulled out their rusty tools and
began to work on him of course the scp
foundation wouldn't take an attack on
one of their operatives inside one of
their facilities no less lying down the
unfortunate death of william birken
allowed the foundation to refine their
methods of intercepting the broadcast of
demon dance commercials they even had a
new mobile task force mobile strike
force kappa 11 or the baphomet bashers
specifically to deal with demon dan and
his cronies they did more than just
prevent him from taking new humans
though when the baphomet bashers teamed
up with an a-class clairvoyant entity to
improve their efficiency in predicting
future broadcasts they were able to
launch sting operations and arrest 21
different demonic customers for
interrogation this impressive strike
back finally gave the foundation some
meaningful leverage over demon dan and
through the use of their clairvoyant
entity they were able to call a
temporary truce and arrange a meeting
with demon dan himself captain steiner
an agent of the foundation external
negotiation department was the one to
interrogate demon dan they sat across
from each other at a table and demon dan
was clearly tense frustrated with the
way the foundation had been messing with
his business all of their sting
operations were frightening off his
customers in return for letting him
continue his work the foundation wanted
dan to turn over all the information on
his bosses and customers allowing the
foundation to track their movements when
dan was evasive about whether he'd
comply they tried threatening him dan
laughed them off go ahead take your best
shot little man there's a dozen more
just like me you won't stop anything
finally he was pressured into giving a
yes or no answer as to whether he'd
willingly collaborate with the
foundation and act as an informant
against his kind when demon dan hinted
that he may be willing to comply he
began to make a horrifying gurgling
noise and gripped his head in pain he
began speaking in latin in a voice that
wasn't his own as though the seven demon
lords he served were speaking through
him they said you are a fool
jailor to think a pathetic morsel such
as this could aid you against us i have
allowed you to toil in your own
delusions for far too long
you may have taken advantage of
azimodius all those years ago but you
stop nothing you hinder nothing you jail
and barter to no avail your time is
coming
and then demon dan's head exploded which
obviously prevented him from giving any
incriminating information on those he
worked for whoever the demon lords are
they're certainly the secretive type you
may think that this is the end of demon
dance discount homunculus depot and of
scp-5049 but soon another ad ran it
advertised the same products and
services out of the same store the only
difference was that this time a
different entity
was starring in it stop me if you've
heard this one before a young man was
driving home from work late one rainy
night when he spotted a woman in a white
dress and a red sweater walking along
the shoulder of the road concerned for
her safety he slowed down and rolled
down the window so he could talk to her
when he asked where she was going she
said she was walking to her parents
house the man pulled over and offered
her a ride that she accepted the woman
gave him the address of her home hopped
in the backseat and the man drove off
she sensed that she must have been cold
from walking in the rain so he cranked
up the car's heater to help her dry off
soon she removed her heavy red sweater
and placed it on the seat next to her
the man tried to make friendly
conversation asking if the woman had a
job what she was studying at school
where'd she been that day but she
remained quiet staring out the window
until they drove past an old graveyard
the woman began pounding on the glass of
the car as if she desperately wanted
something unsure of what to do the man
pulled over but before he could ask her
what was happening she had gotten out of
the car he exited the car to try and
find her but the woman was nowhere to be
seen she must have somehow ran off
confused the man got back in his car and
drove away he went on his way and didn't
think of it again until the next day
when he noticed her sweater was still in
the back of his car he decided to go to
the house she had originally given him
the address for and give it back to her
he found the home without any trouble
but when he knocked on the door the old
woman who answered it was confused by
his story she told them that her
daughter couldn't have possibly left her
sweater in his car because she died in a
car accident 30 years ago the vanishing
hitchhiker is a classic ghost story with
the details varying from place to place
and storyteller to storyteller in
chicago she goes by resurrection mary
named after the graveyard she asks for
rides to in okinawa japan she's known as
the night walker of nago and she only
appears to taxi drivers in kent england
she's suzanne a bride killed in a car
wreck on the way to her bachelorette
party in north carolina her name is
lydia and in hawaii she's believed to be
the goddess pele in human form but as
far as our friends at the scp foundation
are concerned the vanishing hitchhiker's
name is mary tallish also known as
scp-1337 on the 19th of may 1952 college
sophomore mary tallish was abducted on
her way to class in her hometown of
muncie indiana when police found her
body two weeks later her eyes and heart
had been torn from her body in a
ritualistic fashion and she had scrapes
and bruises that suggested she had been
beaten before her murder her killers
were never caught and her body was
returned to her family for burial
intolerance and cemetery starting on the
19th of june that same year someone
matching mary's description a caucasian
woman with blonde hair standing 150
centimeters tall and wearing a red
sweater was spotted trying to flag down
passing vehicles along mayflower road
since then every month on the 19th mary
has been sighted along that stretch of
road and every month the same scenario
plays out mary gives anyone who picks
her up directions to her parents house
then on the way she instructs the driver
to stop at the graveyard where she was
buried she vanishes from the car leaving
her sweater the driver of the car tries
to return the sweater to her parents
house only to be told that mary tallish
was dead when the scp foundation was
made aware of mary talash's pattern of
haunting in the late 50s they set up a
system where agents would patrol
mayflower road at hourly intervals with
the intention of picking mary up agents
were sent on their own in non-foundation
cars and instructed to stick to the
accepted script of the vanishing
hitchhiker legend without attempting to
engage mary in further conversation
mary's parents were also given e-class
agent status to keep them from speaking
about the haunting and told that the
foundation was working on a way to set
the spirit to rest early attempts to
study the apparition were inconclusive
it proved impossible for the foundation
to relocate her or trigger her
manifestation outside of the 19th of
every month and attempts to analyze her
sweater were fruitless since if the
sweater wasn't returned to the tallish
family home it would simply vanish from
containment at or around sunset on the
next 19th for 20 years
scp-1337 events continued to happen as
normal d-class personnel under the
instruction of the foundation would pick
mary up drive her past the cemetery and
return her sweater to her parents it was
business as usual and in fact it was one
of the more sedate reoccurring
apparitions the foundation had to deal
with but as you might have guessed that
piece wouldn't last forever enter dr
lawson who in 1972 was placed in charge
of all resources regarding scp-1337
dr lawson was getting sick of all this
phantom hitchhiker business and while
most of the foundation was happy to keep
this routine going lawson thought that
the continual picking up and dropping
off of mary tallish and her red sweater
was a waste of the foundation's valuable
time after all it was the early 70s the
price of oil was at an all-time high so
the expense of sending car after car up
and down the same road for a solid day
once a month just to pick up a ghost was
more trouble than it was worth so lawson
started developing a plan one that he
didn't go through the proper foundation
channels to approve he reasoned that the
reason mary's ghost kept coming back was
because she wanted something since
always asked for a ride home then it
must mean she wanted to return back to
her parents so logic followed that if
she had nothing or no one to go back to
then she'd stop appearing on the 18th of
june 1973
lawson went ahead with his plan without
his superiors knowledge and ordered the
execution of mary talish's parents as
well as the immediate demolition of
their family home according to his
journals lawson had hoped that his
attempt at decommissioning 1337 would
significantly cut the foundation's gas
bills freeing up valuable funds at which
point he'd surely be promoted in
recognition of his brilliance but that
wasn't what happened lawson was demoted
from team leader to junior staff and
only kept on 1337 detail out of the
belief that without a family to return
to lawson would become the new focal
point of the haunting should mary talish
ever return though lawson's actions
weren't at all above board even by scp
foundation standards they did seem to
have worked the 19th of june came and
went without a single merry sighting and
she wasn't seen the next month either a
full year went by without any sign of
the mayflower road apparition satisfied
with this turn of events the foundation
made the decision to officially
reclassify
scp-1337 from safe to safe
decommissioned and the gas money that
was budgeted for the mayflower road
patrol was redirected to the scp-682
tank acid fund but even though
everything seemed to have been sorted
out boston wasn't entirely satisfied and
not just because of his demotion whether
it was intuition or merely guilt-induced
paranoia is unclear but he suspected
that mary was still out there somewhere
at first he thought that she might show
up on the anniversary of her parents
deaths but then that date came and went
as did eight more anniversaries after it
finally on the 19th of june 1983 lawson
decided he had to see for himself
fitted with recording equipment he drove
alone in a non-foundation standard car
down that lonely stretch of road where
so many before him had stopped to pick
up that mysterious blonde woman with the
red sweater he had to prove to himself
that she wouldn't show up that he had
really and truly gotten rid of her for
good it was about five o'clock in the
evening when he reached mayflower road
at first he didn't experience anything
strange he scanned the roadside looking
for the phantom hitchhiker walking along
it but there was nobody there dr lawson
breathed a sigh of relief he may have
orchestrated the deaths of two innocent
people but at least it hadn't been for
nothing he turned on the recorder he
brought with him and logged that nothing
had happened
scp-1337 had been permanently
neutralized as he approached the
t-intersection and prepared to turn onto
marsh avenue he looked up to adjust his
rear-view mirror to his horror he found
that he wasn't alone in the car someone
was in the seat behind him someone with
blonde hair and a red sweater his last
transmission consisted only of wait who
the hell are you before the recording
abruptly stopped lawson's car was found
soon after by foundation agents lawson
was dead in the front seat bruised and
bloody with his eyes and heart ripped
out in a ritualistic fashion just the
way mary tallish had been found all the
way back in 1952. it turns out that mary
hadn't been neutralized after all she'd
just been waiting for a chance to get
revenge on the man who killed her family
and mary didn't stop with dr lawson no
longer does she appear walking along the
road waiting for someone to offer her a
ride before disappearing without
incident now should someone pass by
without offering a ride she will appear
in their back seat before reenacting the
method of her own death upon the driver
and her physical appearance has changed
too whereas before she looked like the
image of a pretty young woman before her
tragedy now recordings show that she
appears with the wounds of her death
present her eyes gouged out in their
sockets and a massive hole in her chest
where her heart should be the same
wounds she inflicts on her victims the
scp foundation has tried closing off and
eventually destroying the road but that
has only resulted in mary manifesting at
other locations in and around meensy
foundation documents reveal that any
back road in the city can potentially
serve as host to a 1337 event and all
attempts to contain the apparition have
failed the only way someone who has seen
mary can avoid her wrath is by stopping
to pick her up at which point she will
dematerialize before reappearing on
another road mobile task forces have
been unsuccessful as mary only appears
to those driving alone and all agents
who have been sent on solo missions to
apprehend her have resulted in the death
of the agent as cp 1337 was reinstated
this time as euclid class currently the
foundation's method of managing scp-1332
is to dispatch a security team on the
19th of every month to monitor all the
places where a potential siding could
take place as soon as signs of a
manifestation are identified a remotely
controlled vehicle containing a single
d-class is driven to the location once
mary appears in the car the car is
piloted to the empty lot where her home
used to stand and the remains of the
d-class are then disposed of like a lot
of the stories that could pass down as
urban legends the story of
scp-1337 has a lesson that can be taken
away from it this scp started off as an
ordinary local haunting no more deadly
than lydia suzanne resurrection mary or
any of the countless other local
versions of the vanishing hitchhiker
story but thanks to one rogue foundation
doctor and his desire to rush what he
thought would be an efficient solution
the spirit not only became harder to
control but also much more violent and
bloodthirsty than anyone was prepared to
deal with so if there's anything we can
learn here it's that no matter if you're
a student an office worker or a
researcher with the scp foundation think
twice about cutting corners it might
save you a little bit of time and money
in the short term but in the long term
the results could be fatal
if you've ever read the book of genesis
which is the part of the old testament
that details god creating the world and
humanity during a particularly busy week
then you might just be already familiar
with scp-001
or at least one of the anomalies that's
been proposed for the title of scp-001
because of course
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the scp foundation anomaly
sharing the name as cp-001 include the
infamous scarlet king a powerful
eldritch being intent on ending all of
creation that is thought by foundation
researchers to be one of the most
dangerous beings in this and any other
universe but the scarlet king isn't the
only incredibly powerful being
categorized as
scp-001 in fact there are plenty of
other anomalies with similar levels of
destructive power and one such being is
a creature codenamed the gate guardian
standing at well over a thousand feet
tall the gate guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these
scp-001 has historically been seen to
have any number of wings between 2 and
108 sprouting from various places over
its body including its shoulders ankles
wrists and even its temples this
gigantic guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as scp-001-2
this weapon resembles an enormous knife
or sword capable of emitting plumes of
flame according to tests conducted by
the foundation the temperature of the
flames produced by scp-001 rivaled that
of our very own sun for reference the
sun has a core temperature of over 27
million degrees fahrenheit and
5778 kelvin at its surface or almost 10
000 degrees fahrenheit you would expect
a flaming sword that burns hotter than
the sun to cause a considerable amount
of damage even if it wasn't in use but
the flames emitted by the weapon leave
no lasting damage on the surrounding
environment it is capable though of
annihilating anything that strays too
close to
scp-001 burning them so intensely that
their atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
gateway which is equally tall as
scp-001 itself behind the guardian is a
lush grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to scp-001
this grove is thought to be the garden
of eden the paradise that god created
and that was inhabited by adam and eve
the first two humans in existence
according to the book of genesis as the
tale goes the pair were created by god
himself and permitted to live in the
garden of eden as long as they followed
a single rule adam and eve were
instructed not to eat any of the fruit
that grew from certain trees that god
had specified within view just behind
the gate guardian are two immense trees
one bearing apples and the other bearing
different fruit of an unknown type the
one that looks like an apple tree is
believed even by some in the foundation
to be the biblical tree of knowledge
that eve was convinced to pick a fateful
apple from after an encounter with a
snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
gateway and verify if the realm beyond
is truly the bible's own garden of eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of
scp-001 is instantly vaporized the gate
guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nanosecond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at scp-001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
guardian will be able to subatomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving scp-001
on december 26 2004 an scp foundation
nuclear submarine called nautilus
launched a series of multi-warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
depths of approximately 35 000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 boxing day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35 000 victims families
friends and other related individuals in
order to avoid questioning the scp
foundation administered amnestics on an
almost worldwide scale and the o5
council banned any further tests on
scp-008
that involved nuclear weapons in what
was hoped by the foundation to be a test
with lower stakes they sent an
expendable d-class personnel towards
scp-001
the d-class approached the area where
the gate guardian is located and as soon
as they saw it they could hear a very
clear command in their mind
leave
the d-class personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or i would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a thousand foot tall
entity with a flaming sword to tell them
twice the researchers running the
experiment were not swayed by the
request and ordered the d-class to
continue moving towards scp-001
when the d-class continued to ignore
their commands they were terminated as
is standard policy when dealing with an
insubordinate member of d-class
scp-001 appeared not to like this for
some reason though and the researchers
site as well as the researchers
themselves were immediately obliterated
by an unknown force though it's a pretty
safe guess that a certain flaming weapon
was responsible this candidate for
scp-001 may be one of if not the most
powerful being that the scp foundation
has ever encountered and according to
its entry in the scp-001
file the guardian is even responsible
for the creation of the foundation
itself if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the scp foundation one
day heard a word echoing through his
head prepare
this one-word instruction led him to
starting the scp foundation containing
countless dangerous anomalies and
entities in preparation for an uncertain
future in all that time since the very
beginning of the foundation the gate
guardian has remained standing at its
post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards humanity the gate
guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to scp-001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore these
warnings though and scp-001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality
given its enormous destructive potential
it is no wonder that the foundation has
tried to use the gate guardian to
eliminate other dangerous scps each with
varying results the foundation at one
time even attempted to use the gate
guardian to destroy the infamously
indestructible scp-682
better known by the appropriate name of
the hard to destroy reptile due to the
malicious contempt
scp-682 holds for human beings and all
other forms of life it is perhaps one of
the most dangerous anomalies the scp
foundation has in containment
scp-682 is also one of the few creatures
the foundation actively wants to
terminate a task made that much harder
given that 682 can regenerate its entire
form from as little as a single cell the
gate guardian had already shown time and
time again that it was capable of
massive destruction and researchers
working for the foundation hoped to
harness that power to rid the world of
scp-682 for good 682 was placed on an
unmanned vehicle and carried to within
one kilometer of the gate guardian the
guardian attacked the vehicle seriously
wounding but not killing 682 it seemed
even the mighty
scp-001 couldn't kill the hard to
destroy reptile while the researchers
were disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate guardian is not
uriel but a pretender uriel is the
archangel that some religious texts
describe as the guardian standing at the
gate of eden with a fiery sword so does
this mean that 682 knows that the gate
guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the garden of eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the scp
foundation a later experiment involved
both
scp-001 and scp-073
the anomaly otherwise known as cain kane
is a male humanoid of possible arabic
descent whose arms legs spine and
shoulders are replaced in an almost
cyborg-like fashion with beryllium
bronze much like the gate guardian
scp-073 may also be the same as the one
mentioned in the bible's book of genesis
who according to the biblical story
murdered his own brother abel out of
spite as punishment for his actions kane
was cursed to eternally suffer for his
wrong doing in the case of
scp-073 any damage inflicted on him is
deflected back to the attacker but kane
is made to feel the pain of the attack
any plants or plant-based matter withers
and rots in his presence and he is
cursed with a perfect memory keeping him
forever haunted by his murder of abel
when cain was brought before the gate
guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on
scp-001 the encounter left scp-07
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
o5 council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on scp-008
with the administrator even filing an
executive order that no scps be exposed
to the guardian and that
scp-001 was to never be used for the
attempted termination of other scps of
course perhaps it wasn't just the
mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that scp-001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site zero
by foundation personnel detailing an xk
class end of the world scenario in the
transmission the sender believed to be
another member of the scp foundation
described an event during which the gate
guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the garden of
eden
scp-001 has left its location the sender
wrote the gate is open they are riding
forth oh god it's so beautiful the
transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the lord shall
reign forever and hear o israel the lord
our god the lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
god deems it time his angelic armies
will lay ways to the earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
as cp001 the gate guardian will open the
gate he stands in front of allowing the
other beings like it to emerge into our
world ready to cleanse it perhaps most
interesting is the source of the message
the transmission was received from
within the foundation from site zero
however when questioned by personnel
05-14 told them that no such message had
been sent or even existed while some
disregarded the transmission telling of
the end of the world as a hoax it was
then that a timestamp was discovered
this warning had not been sent from site
zero at least not yet and was dated
several years in the future despite this
ominous warning of things to come the
gate guardian remains inactive standing
at the threshold to eden waiting
you